journ bonjour à tous et on a un derby un
match cocorican
entre Maxime vachagrave et alira firouja
et j'ai envie de dire quand même malheur
au vaincu aujourd'hui parce que nos deux
joueurs ferment un peu la marche du
tournoi ils ont ils ont qu'une seule
victoire un petit coup classement un
petit coup classement là hop pour être
bien sûr de ce que je raconte et ils ont
qu'une seule victoire en 4atre matchs et
donc il ferment la marche en compagnie
de Denis lazavic et Ikaru Nakamura en tu
appelles lazavic alors qu' a un cas je
sais pas ça sonne mieux
lazavic en fait ouais mais en fait j'ai
pas l'habitude je sais pas ça sonne
croate pour moi alors qu'en fait il est
pas du tout cro pas cro il est Bor c'est
pour ça fait je demande que depuis hier
c'est que tu lazavic lazavic mais c'est
pas du ça sort tout seul en fait ah
d'accord mais mais je suis quasiment sûr
que c'est ENF je suis même pas quasiment
je suis sûr que c'est laavic en
faitation
ouais ouais ouais et ben
laavic il a l'air encore plus nul dit
comme ça en
faitavic tu te dis a quelque chose c'est
du Modric c'est Rakitic tuis c'est beau
joueur de foot quoi tu l'as par modrick
tu t'attendrais un genur de CFA quoi ENF
qui joue à je sais pas moi à
saint-étienour quoi enfin ça pourrait
jouer à Saint-Étienne non ça pourrait ça
pourrait pour moi ça
pourrait et et donc tout l'enjeu donc de
ce ce match entre entre Maxime et alira
c'est c'est dépasser la dépasser laav et
espérer pas finir les deux derniers donc
forcément il y aura un battu ils peuvent
pas faire que des nuls enfin ils ont
faire de nuls il y aura un Armagedon
donc il y aura un vainqueur dans ce dans
ce match et c'est parti défense
française choisie par alirea je crois
que les n'est pas très bien
centré alors attends euh que se
passe-t-il attends ouais ouis ou rien n
centré en fait je vois bien il y a rien
qui va ah là ça va voilà désolé un petit
petit difficulté
réi alors on VO Maxime habiller de bleu
face à fou tout de rouge vêtu un peu un
petit chaperon qui joue une une
française il a une capuche ah ben oui il
peut se capucher hein comme un chaperon
c'est
normal est-ce que le rouge est bien
rouge d'après toi c'est pas sûr c'est un
rouge je serait pas trop bon comment le
qualifier mais il est pas scintillant
comme rouge mais bon il est quand même
rouge quo je troume très rouge rouge
rouge rou quoi non mais ou alors c'est
les balances des caméras mais il est
vraiment non bah c'est ou mais je sais
pas comment sont balancé les caméras en
tout cas bon on voit bien que ça matche
français Maxime de en bleu blanc il y a
les raés je pens qu'il ont fait exprès
bah peut-être il aur pas fait ils
auraient pas fait différemment s' avent
fait exprès
doncon c'est une française c'est un peu
ton ton territoire Fab un petit peu donc
là tu comprends à fond la
partie
ouais je comprends bien dame B6 ne
menace pas le pion B2 par contre
attention alors pourquoi parce que sur
dame prend B2 on pourra jouer cavalier
A4 attaque la dame prend toutes les
cases de fuite d'où l'intérin d'un pion
A3 à la fois défendre la case à3 par sa
présence ouvrant la tour et la ce
B4 quand la dame prend allez on va
attendre le prochain coup mais par
contre tu as pas envie de jouer dame D2
c'est un peu anti dame D2 dame B6 parce
que dame D2 tu pourrais prendre B2
plusou tour ser attaquer
euh après peut-être un PERP sur la dame
ou quoi mais bon peu importe c'est pas
le but non plus de quand tuas les blan
de faire nul comme ça
euh donc on pourrait s'attendre
peut-être
euh dans
ok il a pris j'hésit à faire un fou de
ou quoi Caval A4 donc peut-être dame à 5
B qu dame prend A4 et donc paire de fou
gagné par les Blancs et en fait les
blancs adoreraient jouer C4
pour échanger les dames et surtout
enlever les pions doublés ouvrir un peu
la position pour que les fous puissent
parler mais c'est théorique ça je sais
pas c'est théorique là mais je connais
le thème j'ai déjà eu dans des positions
un peu similaires quoi mais genre tu
connais la position là non pas du tout
peutre
je peut-être que je l'ai déjà joué via
d'autres ordres de coup
perso mais mais en tout cas ouis je sais
que les veul faire 4 donc dame a 5 échec
il va falloir jouer dame D2 j'imagine
sinon on va perdre le pion C5 mais je
pensais que c'était mieux pour les
blancs sur final quasi même enfin
gagnant j'y vais peut-être un peu fort
mais c'est pas genre un net avantage
bon ça tellement jouer vite en face que
je me demande tu prends du roi tu mets
le PI en C3 la tour en B1 le fou en E2
tu reviens tu rejoues tour B2 tour B1 tu
mets le truc sur D4 tu échanges mets le
fou en D3 tu enfin ouais mais je bon moi
je crois en C4 mais
euh
euh non je préfère les blancs oua enfin
Maxime se barre ko passe devant la cam
il a le même habillement Quiou même pull
petit rock de il n pas changé son pull
peut-être qu'il l'a plusieurs fois le
même sinon il est sale bon après un pull
tu peux le mettre Dejour de suite ça
peut arriver ouais mais c'est un peu
sale quand même non non mais bon tu vois
il perd un peu il a peut-être pas les
moyens de de prendre les les 1000 balles
par match gagné il se dit ah je peux pas
petite pull je on verra
je ah on a eu un petit bug micro désolé
c'est revenu c'est revenu ok en fait
c'est que tu app un peu sur la table et
le truc avec les branchements et tout
désolé peu non mais pas vraiment ta
faute mais juste il est devenu un tout
petit peu capricieux parfois ça devrait
pas réarriver vraiment
désolé petit problème de de
branchement F en
D3
non la position l'air tellement bien
ouais bah mieux blanc en fait je sais
pas pourquoi jou si vite ce truc bon moi
je pensais que c'était pas pour mais
alors soit en fait on va découvrir que
finalement c'est pas si mal qu'il a un
plan une idée et ben tant mie on
apprendra quelque chose ou alors une
partie
ratée il en rate beaucoup des
partiesza il joue
vraiment
c'est moins sa période après on verra
comme tu disais peutêtre un joueur de
Rush et
voilà il fait
F6 il fait F6 ouais bon ça je
m'attendais à ce qu'il le joueçon c'est
le seul moyen de
bouger on va sûement devoir le prendre
ce pion et je pense qu'il vudra
reprendre du cavalier ou peut-être de G
pour essayer de faire 5 mais moi je
prend du cavalier quandme mais peut-être
c'est de la merde CER je sais pas
trop
cavalier bon l'idée serait de venir
vers4 Esser de donner la ce D7 pour le
fou et de bouger un peu comme ça c'est
ce qu'
fait horrible sur les VO bien qui en B1
qui bloque le fou ouais je vois pas
de c'est
catastrophique non mais vraiment F je
j'ai du
mal je suis étonné
quoi jusqu'à maintenant c'est vrai qu'on
va pas de on en parlait hier ce matin
hier soir entre nous ce matin mais on n
pas vu de de très belles parties jusqu'à
maintenant pas de parti marquante là sur
les premiers jours non sur ce qu'on a vu
pas trop après bon peut-être qu' y a
trop d'enjeux dans ce tournoi et que
l'enjeu ouais dépasse le jeu peut-être
peut-être ça mais c'est vrai parce que
les joueurs ont vraiment toutes les
conditions réunies pour bien jouer on
vraiment tout on le met pas de public
pour pas qu' ça soit dérangé on met des
petites pauses pas trop longues mais un
petit peu quand même qui se repose pour
pas trop enchaîner
quand même 15 minutes par partie pour
avoir le temps de bien réfléchir soit
pas trop rapide et pourtant
non c'est vrai qu'ils sont mis dans les
conditions optimal pour pour bien jouer
c'est tant mieux c'est ce qu'on veut ils
ont les beaux sièges secret Lab il y a
pas de il y a pas de bruit alors après
il y a pas de on 'entend pas le bruit
j'ai même regardé sur le stream en
anglais on n pas le retour bruit des
pièces sur les chiqu du réel en fait
donc on sait pas du tout enfin on n pas
de retour sur l'atmosphère que j'ai
trouvé personnellement un peu bizarre ça
me fait penser c'est comme si on enlevit
le son quand AA du tennis ou du foot
mais mais bon après c'est pour que les
gens soient pas dérangés non plus quand
il tu puisse bien suivre pu bien suivre
ouais donc on n pas complètement sûr de
ça mais ouais ils ont ils sont dans des
conditions optimal on n pas eu de de
super partie jusqu'à maintenant on en
avait eu aus grandes cha tourez
mémorable celle de firouja contre si tu
te rappelles o firou la dame très jolie
partie ouais ouais tu l'as d'ailleurs
Comé sur ta chaîne non ça céit une belle
partie voilà ça c'est
marquant on a pas eu l'équivalent pour
l'instant on verra
inf faut capital la chemise que portait
hier firou coûte 1825 dollars moi je
croyais que c'était un kimono Robin sa
ouais ça ressembl enfin je trouvais que
le Kim rouge était peut-être même plus
saant quoi on sait que c'est vrai
c'était un kimono après c'est vrai on
l'a déjà dit les joueurs de haut niveau
et c'est tant mieux gagnent des sommes
astronomiques tu peux avir des de belles
chemises ce qui fait ce qui en fait un
des sports et on a de la chance les
mieux payés au monde en peut même le
mieux payé au monde en terme de en terme
de spectateur par ratio quoi on va dire
ouais ce qui est beau mais là le pull à
mon avis vu le pull je crois que c'est
un pull qui doit coûter très très cher
aussi il aime bien les habits de luxe et
il a
raison toujours une
bonne manière de dépenser son argent on
peut aussi dépenser son argent FEM en
achant des displates exactement euh euh
moi j'aime bien che Zidane
ouais
je te le piquer je pense un jour tu
auras le dos tourné B je vois je vois
que tuas la caméra quand même pour
regarder dans ton dos donc faudra que je
sois très discret quoi faut vas-y je
t'en
prie mais le display de Zidane je trouve
très joli donc fou D7 joué par alirea
qui veut se développer et tour B1 va
jouer très vite par Maxime mais une
pression le long de de la colonne B
alors l' dit bon coup en même temps
c'est un coup logique on se place on
tape là-bas et donc pour défendre ça va
inciter des coups passifs comme tour B8
k D8 des choses comme ça qu'on na pas
trop envie de jouvec les Noirs bon je
pense tour B8 hein k D8 vraiment pas
envie parce qu'on laisserait arriver le
Cavalier Blanc E5 et euh c'est pas
fantastique mais forcément t B8 c'est
moins bien que T bien ce t bien on voit
toutes les cases contrôler le long de
cette colonne B vers l'avant alors que
la tour B8 bon ben ce canton a juste
avoir un rôle très défensif mais donc
allera qui espère peut-être à terme
arriver à ressortir la tête de l' a S
fou
euh
mais mais Ben mieux quand même blanc
clairement la position elle donne pas
très envie côté noir c'est une
catastrophe cette partie
d'Alia mais du coup euh une victoire lui
permet de d'acheter une demi-chemise
seulement parce que tu parlais des 1000
€ pardon euh c'est quoi des 1000 € B
tuas pas dit 1000 € par victoire si si
si si pardon euh ouais si la chemise
coûte 1800 faut en gagner deux faut
gagner de ouais faut gagner aujourd'hui
ça fera la deuxième victoire alors je
sais pas si c'est par partie gagné ou
par mini match gagné je pense que c'est
par mini match gagné
mais donc en plus hein des prix au
général c'est juste un petit bonus pour
la route ah il y a un travail de
reporter tu robinide qui donne de très
belles informations
ou 1825 c'est le baroco silk shirt je
mise en soit avec des petits dragons
dessus mon vrai peut-être qu'il l' a
acheté en en promo en solde en black
Frid
day je trouve c'est vraiment une impin
c'est peut-être l'information principale
de ce champion ch jusqu'à
maintenant on VO peut-être la marque du
pull là enfin moi je vois mal
[Musique]
mais mais moi je dis que ça ressemble à
un pull très cher
h est-ce qu'on pour avoir l'info dans le
chat est-ce que quelqu'un a une info sur
sur ce
pull donc cas Maxime qui améliore petit
à petit sa position
elle a un magnifique contrôle des cases
noires bah à part l'absence du Fou
adverse et puis la structure quand tu 5
évidemment les cases noires elles sont
pas couvertes tout tu peux gagner un
pion mais après à savoir est-ce que ce
sera assez pour gagner c'est un peu la
question ouais bon bonne question
d'ailleurs non prend pr G5 les no sû il
vont jouer E5 on prend4 il prendront F4
peut-être le fou sera moins mauvais et
tr contre de dame c'est dur de valoriser
alors c'est toujours mieux pour les
blancs quoi qu'
en qui peut tomber je sais pas c'est
compliqué
Maxime qui se lève on aimerait bien voir
se lever pour voir ce qu'il a écrit sur
sur le
pull mais est-ce que ça pourrait être du
versa encore je pense pas que versa un
pull rouge comme
ça donc il a ramené le cavalier a 4 euh
ok donc il évite les fou prend E4 et qui
les
G5 en faisant en faisant cette petite
manœuvre ce saut de cabri jusqu'en
A4 donc à voir ce que Maxime compte
jouer
maintenanon que c'est moins pire que ce
que ça pu être pour enfin c'est toujours
tuas toujours pas envie d'avoir les
Noirs mais je trouais que c'était plus
dégueulasse il coup la position enfin je
suis d'accord avec
toi c'est un pull suprême à 420 € c'est
possible qui écrit suprême ce que j'ai
vu em
h 350
ouais ah c'est lui ouais c'est ce pull
mais ils sont efficaces hein vous savez
tout
bravo vousz les superbes polo Blitz
Stream qui sont un peu pareil mais qui
sont que à 55
€ du coup moins bien moins cher en tout
cas pas ass cher mon
fils
son ces polo et ses sit et tout les Ood
bah écoute j'ai envie d'augmenter les
prix que je vois ça 350 balleson
menace cavalier à 5 on nous dit dans le
chat comment ça menace ben je sais
pas cal à 5 t B4
non faer tour quand même6 T b
qui et c'est de nouveau à moi de jouer
quoi en plus qui C6 on pr 4 peut-être
sur la route possible donc là
bon on est magnifique
quoi est-ce qu' des infos sur le pull de
Maxime Maxim nous qui le connaissons un
petit peu il est pas trop dans délire
des des vêtements de luxe non il met des
trucs normau bien quoi mais pas pas
luxe on allait faire du shopping un peu
à jbraltar des fois avec Mazo qui
adoré c'est moins cher non
c'est vraiment pas ouais ouais c'était
la période de B janvier là où tuas un
peu des soldes je crois que les Anglais
font particulièrement des soldes en fait
fait et donc il fait double sold enfin
cétait à Gibraltar c'était les trucs
anglais c'était
fou le fou
g est-ce que tu as songé à faire du
march pendant la backup
euh non ça rapporte ça rapporte rien en
réalité c'est pas quelque chose
d'intéressant plus pas trop le temps
Maxime c'est un pull
Kabi Puma à 60 €
oui il sont hy comment vous trouvez en
fait ils sont extraordinaires en fait je
pense qu'on va parler que vêtement
maintenant pendant tous les tourno enfin
vous êtes des
génies ils connaissent les les promos
tout ou alors ils ils ont il y a une
personne qui a le même et ils savent il
y a peut-être quelqu'un qui travaille
là-dedans il reconnaî facilement c'est
tellement plus utile de connaître ça que
les ouvertures aux échecs s'en F bah oui
je REC les vêtements très
vite fa Fab une chemise toute pourrie
quoi d'ailleurs au
moi toi c'est toi c'est de la grande
qualité B oui oui forcémentus qui a 4
ans et qui marche toujours aussi bien
j'ai l'ancienne version mais c'était
très qualitatif ouais 20
€. il paraît qu'Al resa a une chemise de
malade sous son
pull possible en tout cas il gagne bien
sa vie c'est tant
mieux ça c'est sûr que nos amis de
lursaf sont peut-être en train de
scruter hein ces vêtons de luxe ah ah ah
si tu as full chemise à 2 3000 balles ah
ouais tu peux pas déclarer 500 par moi
oui oh que non
que
non on espère qu'ils sont là scruté quoi
il jumelle
quoi que si tu as 300 chemises comme
ça tous les jours et tout tous outfit il
sont à 7 8000
€s sont
là bonjour
monsieur pour vérifier de TR trucs
et toi c'est quoi ta chemise du coup je
sais même pas en fait je suis pas sûr
que c'est très connu je trouvé à
Saint-Étienne donc déjà forcément ça
peut pas être c'est pour ça que personne
ne la trouvé en fait ouais personne sait
en fait non mais je trouvais pas trop
mal voilà pas un pion pas vraiment par
qu'il récupère C5 mais t il est mieux
Maxime quand même question c'estir s'il
peut gagner ou
pas j'ai toujours pas reçu de mail pour
mon prix de la BUP frérot c'est c'est il
est hyper stressant French
Fighter toujours
stressant pendant des jours sur le chat
frérot c'est c'est pas la
secondeéit dimanche on est quand même
lundi là et non mais bon ça sera fait
moi je sais pas j'ai moi j'ai pas reçu
de
prix mais ça doit être via le le Bullet
j'imagine ouais il faut quelques
quelques jours quand même mais bon les
[Musique]
gens ça va je pense je me porte garant
des organisateurs
et je me porterai pas à ta place hein
tant pis au pire je porte garant pas moi
qui payeraai hein
mais mais je pense pas qu'il y aura
d'arnaque
voilà donc tour B6
jouet
F C4 cavalier A4 prendcheends 6 au pire
quoi sûrement du f
C4 sil
veut bon toute façon là il faut faire
quelque chose prend D3 donc soit
repartir avec du roi D2 soit f C4 qui
l'vite et ben faut regarder pr 4 mais
voilà pourquoi pas enfin les deux coup
sont
cohérents
8 ok bon mieux Maxime
mais faut quand même jouer un peu précis
je pense non après il a pris une grosse
avance
autant
qu' y a plus que 2 minutes en face
contre 9 minutes
blanches là il faut être un peu précis
ouais on va voir s'il y arrive
hein
nit pas une grande partie une nouvelle
fois quoi qu'il en soit bah un peu à
sens unique mais voir si ça va être
réalisé ou pas que dire par là c'est pas
des fois tu parti en c'est pas mal parce
que tu dis tiens elles sont pas mal pour
un livre ou quoi elles sont propres ou
quoi mais là non elle a pas elle sera
pas dans un livre pas pour l'instant je
pas une partie tu as envie d'analyser ou
de revoir non non mais vraiment non oui
enfin je sais bien dis c'est un peu une
partie de merde en fait c'est dur de
faire des belles parties c'est dur
d'être précis en fait à ce jeu déjà on n
pas on a pas encore eu c'est ce que
c'est par rapport à ça on a pas encore
eu de de partie
vraiment marquante ok ça c'est vraiment
une super partie tu as envie même de la
montrer de l'analyser ou quoi on en a
pas eu encore mais j'en voit plus si
souvent mais bon ben celle que dont tu
as parlé de de saut contre firouja
c'était vraiment ça c'était quelque
chose il y avait la fameuse de Douda là
qui était sympa mais sans être une
grande partie mais elle est belle juste
techniquement mais tu vois je pense ces
deux là sur les deux tris derniers mois
quoi j'en pense pas ouais mais après il
y en aussi dans l'enjeu qui on pu être
sympa au grand Suisse le machin oui
nakakwana par exemple ou et puis qui
était pas mal aussi pour lui pour le
coup était bien jouer
ouis c'est que parfois tu as des belles
enfin tu as plusieurs choses qui peuvent
faire une partie quand même que tu as
envie de voir ou revoir ou analyser
c'est vrai que là pour le moment on en a
pas
eu
mais une question de chance pour le
coup la première de darda contre B qui
était
sympa partie celle de la garde
contre
de il pas bienô cas
no
pas j'ai pas bien vu les poules pour le
coup donc je demandais en fait je sais
en face finale j' dirais les deux là
elles étaient tu as deux parties qui
étaient
sympas pourquoi il fait pas qu' pr je
pense qu'il a pas envie de perdre une
pièce en
fait trop de défenseur côté
noir sur ce pion E6 ouais c'est ça ça
c'est le max garde contre Baky ouais
c'est parti que tu as envie de revoir
pour voir comment s'est passé ce truc là
parce que c'est un peu fou quoi ouais
comment c'est possible quoi
commentun coup le roi tout seul qui ve
une attaque de mat c'est
rare que c'était John snow la bataille
des bâtards quoi h se de c'est marant
c'est dommage qu'il a pas gagné
derriurre max garde ça
ouais
mais je sens no deux joueurs français
quand même un peu en dessous he dans
cette compétition jusqu'à
maintenant pe s Maxime va à la gagner
enfin bon peut-être que si hein parce
que ça joue encoreant de temps
ouais donc il se redirige vers5 avec ce
cavalier il peut peut-être perdre un
pion sur qu' il prend des tro tour C3
mais je penseal après cavalier à4 ouais
et B5 ouais ben il se fait
chasser ah je veux bien croire que tu
égalis une fois que tu as fait ça B oui
logique tu repris de l'espace et plus
cette tour fort en B6 Tom as plus ce
pion qui est mauvais pu tu as plus ce
pion 6 sous pression tu as le fou qui
revient en B7 enfin tout d'un coup tu as
réglé quand même pas mal de problème
ouais
tu es retours déjà de la commune derère
sur ce type d'événement bah écoute les
retours que j'ai eu j'en ai eu plein
plein plein pour le moment et tous les
gens sement dire que c'était un Banger
mais après que c'était super après voilà
moi c'est un type d'événement si j'ai
pas s'il y a pas de gros budget pour
pour en réorganiser un j'en referai pas
non plus parce que marre de faire des
trucs super et d'avoir
50 fois ou 100 fois moins d'argent que
les autres donc on verra écoute les
bases sont posées mixé où
maintenant on verra on verra bien
comment ça se
passe cavalier C3 et non Maxime il fait
vraiment une mauvaise partie les deux
font une mauvaise partie mais du coup
les PE être plus content
ouais vu d'où il
vient
ouais il y a pour quelqu'un pour qui
c'est vraiment bien de gagner ce r ou
pas ouais alors là partx en fait c'est
un match qui est vraiment important pour
les deux par qu'ils sont tous les deux
très mal classés et donc c'est un
peu de la survie quoi de la survie ouais
malheur au perdant celui qui gagne se
place quand même pas mal pour ce Calif
au barrage et celui qui perd se met en
grande difficulté après je pense que
c'est plus grave encore pour Maxime de
perdre qu'il a il a déjà jouav VI et il
a encore à jouer
Magnus Magnus c'est un adversaire qui
réussit plutôt bien à maxi mais bon
ouais c'est ça Maxime il enchaîne par
Carlsen alors queou enchaîne la
zavic donc si Maxime perd et qui perd
contre Carlsen bon c'est quand même même
si Maxime est un bon c'est pas le pire
adversaire pour lui c'est quand même pas
illogique perdre Carlsen quoi
ça peut arriver ça arrive à des gens
bien
est qu' que la FFE participe la
prochaine fois les félicitations récolt
alors la FFE ils ont pas d'argent
là ils sont tout autant dans la h que
nous en
fait
peutreon Peiser la H Cup avec eux
quoi ils sont en H aussi
hein non faut du sponsoring privé un peu
plutôt non
ouais et de l'argent propre que renchou
en ce qui est jamais super
facile
a 4 qui C5 qui revient
non Maxime il s'est
fait mystifier une très bonne partie
ou il sont une super condition d'air
aujourd'hui ouais j'ai vu l'air est bon
aujourd'hui il est pas fer il est good
ouais c'est ça qui m'étonne
aussi température parfaite 24 bonne
humidité ouais ouais
c'est je pense qu'ils ont mis des petits
brumisateurs un peu pour l'humidité ils
ont aéré ils ont et puis il y a pas
grand monde dans la salle aussi ce qui
permet de pas avoir trop de CO2 donc il
y a tout ce qu'il
faut
ah écouté plus de 20 originau de Ly girl
inspiré des
échecs du coup ça y est j'ai compris ce
que c'est ce Lofi quoi mais c'est très
bien li tu très heureux deofi non mais
c'est pas quelqu'un en fait c'est un
type de musique mus sais pas moi j'ai
jamais écouté mais enfin j'ai écouté
sans le savoir en fait c'est li
ouis
mais du coup je suis très heureuse que
lyar c'est quoi ça son nom d'artiste ou
c'est du coup c'est bien parce qu'elle
fait de la musique lofie à fond quoi un
instrument que j'aime bien là mais je
sais pas comment il s'appelle c'est le
truc où il tape là mais tu as écouté le
l fig girl du coup sur les écheacs bah
là non je viens de voir le message je
peux
pas il tu pu tomber dessus ah j'ai
jamais écouté
de mais tu on voit les vidéos des fois
c'est un
c'est pas du tout un un jum ou quoi
c'est ouais c'est métallique son et gen
des fois ils en joue aussi aux animaux
aux vaches ou quoi es sont elles sont
super heureuses et bah moi aussi en fait
je suis là je je sais pas ce que c'est
cet instrument j'adore
quoi mais mais très bien le figure bravo
j'écouterai éc la playlist su par le
streamlabs que je parler de Isou en
partant de la B et ISU a fait
l'actualité aujourd'ui parce qu'il m'a
dit qu'il partait dans les ivelines qui
don lescliptique il est parti M dit je
par dans les
ivelines tu n'habites pas loin de la
commune de Issou
ine donc Isou a fait l'actualité
aujourd'hui je suis pas au courant mais
c'est l' Fidelity ouais mais je sais pas
pour ce qu' vient faire fidéity dedans
mais je sais
pas
coute partie
terne après l'avantage c'est qu'on peut
avoir une deuxième la partie d'après
avoir l'ARM magadon voilà tout façon vit
pour les armes Guedon c'est vent le gros
point fort de de ces tournoi c'est beau
les armes gedon
j'adore d'Illes peut-être peut-être pour
faire un tournoi à enchère juste
tu es tout le temps en enchère tout le
temp
Ener
et peut-être on fait un petit confession
à avant tu vas expliquer tes enchères
oui je vais dire ça parce que je veux
les blancs ou parce que je pense que lui
il va dire ça il va avoir le seum et
cetera et cetera le chat c'est pas Robin
qui avait dit fauditfin faire un T juste
d'en cher
tu mets zéro tout le temps non faut le
comprendre peut-être je sais pas en fait
c'est un autre jeu c'est pas les échecs
en fait c'est un jeu d'enchère et Tuch
sur des trucs aprend de la valeur enfin
ok pas pour pas pour un chrono quoi mais
non tu quand même faire un avec les
joueurs d'échec enfin de toute façon au
bout d'un moment il fait penser à
l'émission avec Sophie d'avance sur
France 2 là où il vendent des trucs ils
en chérissent
quoi Michel c'est la plus
belle en centaines de milliers d'euros
ça car ça en fait je pense il sert
absolument à rien il est beaucoup trop
cher pour ce qu' rapporte qu' rapporte
quasiment pas grandchose en fait
euh mais en vrai un joueur que
j'aimerais bien avoir c'est Guiry moi
j'aime bien Guiry tu tu me demandis je
pense qu' rapport qualité prix Guiry est
1000 fois mieux que Carlsen si je visis
un joueur du top hors Maxime je viserai
Guiry parce qu'il est puis je pense
qu'il est un peu dans la même vis je
sais pas un
bon j'ai un bon feeling avec gu premier
degré j'ai un bon feeling puis Carlsen
il y a des trucs aussi qui me plaisent
pas forcément je personnag ça après
c'est de l'ordre du du privé mais euh
mais du coup je viserai plus du
Guiry le double
i thodor hier c'était cataclyismique
alors elle coûtait 1850 € quand même
Théodor donc ouais tu ne comprends
absolument rien à la mode tu es
complètement fermé ouais bon ok en fait
tu es complètement fermé on va te
retirer d'ailleurs le prix de l'élégance
je crois après cette
intervention acheté ça50 €
c'est et donc là peut-être qu'il a fini
par
gaffer je
crois VI pour
Maxime une partie qui ne restera pas
dans les anales
Fab
bon fa encore finir mais bon il bouffer
tous les pions en plus je CIS tu peux
commencer par tour 6 F7 du coup tu vas
pouvoir tant mieux pour
Maxime si on veut espér avoir deux
joueurs français faut plutôt une
victoire de
Maxime propose que le PN de chaque
partie vendrait ses vêtements au en
cherception c'est très
bien le but du to c'est finir avec le
plus de fric à la fin ou enfin par
rapport au fric investi peut-être en en
ratio en pourcentage quoi c'est serait
1850 €
[Rires]
mdr exceptionnel je fais des études en
mod
regarde je CIS que en fait c'est voou
alors un juste prise du le coup des
vêtements adverse tu prends d'avantage a
temp mais là tu veux pas trouver là Eton
fait du coup il sera hyper fort par mon
il sa jamais ouais 20 € c'est 1850 vous
avez
perdu
dommage t t à 6 il ve k B6 mais ro
C5 fa peut-être éviter
ça tour D6 tour C6 tour C6 plus logique
ouais et puis il va commencer avancer
ses pions peut-être en prier comme
tuôles
F1
ah
non toujours pas de TPR 6 à cause de la
fourchette mais fou prend ça fait de
pions de
plus B6 sûrement t H6 H6
ouais remplacer le
fou qui qui va se cacher et les pions
qui vont avancer petit à petit il y a
pas grand chose à faire côté
noir ça aait été beau hier quand même
que que so perde la partie il a la dame
de plus mais c'était pas si loin cétait
pas si loin mais là Maxime il s'est un
peu embrouillé les pers je crois
qu'elleit manger à 6 c'était pas
forcément utile
he 6 c'est quoi t
C4
est qu'
5 ça va aller mais ILM les pinceaux
aussi
Maxime j'ai bien cette expression les
pinceaux
ouais F5 focalise ce
cavalier faire tour à 4 F3 et tour à 5
mieux caché là-bas et tour C7 ouais et
là ça y est ça va gagner donc coup il
fait tour à 3 mais direct s d'ailleurs
on D6 je pense
ouais et on va prendre ce cavalier qui
sera porté de ouais victoire de Maxime
contre alira finalement dans une partie
assez terne assez terne il a loupé ce
tour PR 6 et Maxim Sosé carwan a battu
la zavic ikarou a gagné cl contre
abdorov et et euh et on a Carl senso les
leader qui vont faire nul petite nul
après çate
pas jolie
ouais qui a donné sa tour pour faire un
et ça il y a un Magnus Magus ikaro est
rentré dans son tournoi enfin il a l'air
d'avoir fait une belle partie pour le
coup pu on final a l'air sympa il avait
les Noirs une une
[Musique]
calache tu as très bien joué de la part
d'abdousador enfin
[__] je comprends pas en fait non mais
j'ai joue des calages depuis 15 ans
ouais ça m jamais arrivé de voir ça
ouais et non mais je dire il y a déjà eu
la dernière ronde contre Risi là où
c'était ridicule ce qu'il avit joué bon
tu dis ok il fait de surprise je sais
pas ilortte pas la pression bon mais là
c'est une partie minable en fait
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça quoi en fait
c'est mal joué de part et d'autre parce
que du coup il s pas retrouvver c'est
une partie
horrible oh la kata
il était de nouveau perdant soitdisant
avec la petite truc mais ou il y a que
des coup rouges en
fait
bon F analyser mais je crois que la
partie est cataclismique
aussi on se retrouve après la pause m
messieurs allez à tout à l'heure et
petite pub
avant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on est on est reparti Fab
alors rond 2 entre les Français et une
bah une une nashdorf avec un petit coup
d' md3
pasrican ma Maxime ah attends on est on
est à l'envers euh c'està dire euh j'ai
pas pensé mais en fait on est on est à
l'envers ok donc faut qu'on retourne les
chiqu on est à l'envers en fait ah parce
qu'ils ont les caméras à l'envers
attends on est
ch Paron ENF c'est juste que c'est la
grave avec la tête d'za et vice vera
quoi ou alors attends non mais en fait
ouais c'est ça c'est qu'on a juste
changé on est complètement à
l'envers
ça les changer pas d'affolement et donc
après ce coup d'AM D3 il y a eu B7 fou
de jou et G6 pour développer le fou en
fiet donc dame D3 coup un peu rare mais
pourquoi pas ça peut préparer le grand
rock ça peut préparer une arrivée de la
dame vers l'ERI en G3 ou par là-bas
alors tu as eu des infos sur les règles
Fab info importante oui non je ve
question ça c'est pas pour aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est très clair on sait les
matchs et cetera mais donc comme en fait
c'est cette ronde le
tournoi n tiens demain peut-être il y a
qu'un match en a deux par jour mais en
fait alors pas vraiment ils vont
commencer la la la la phase de je sais
pas on appelle ça en fait mais de
barrage barrage en gros ouais donc si
vous avez bien compris le le tournoi ce
qu'on vous explique là pour l'instant
c'est une phase de poule les deux
premiers le vainqueur de la phase de
poule et le second seront qualifiés
directement pour les demi-finales il
restera deux strapontins à obtenir pour
ces demi-final euh alors autant les
joueurs numéroos 7 et 8 donc le dernier
l'avant-dernier seront définitivement
éliminés les autres se qualifient pour
la phase de barrage donc le 3e va jouer
contre le 4e et le 5e contre le 6e alors
on pe se dire ah tiens pourquoi comment
mais simplement parce que le 3e contre
le 4e le vainqueur sera directement
qualifié pour les pour les demi-finales
le match entre le 5e et le 6e le
vainqueur affrontera le perdant d'autre
match le perdant lui pour le coup sera
définitivement éliminé et donc on aura
le un autre match ensuite entre donc le
perdant du match 3e 4e et le vainqueur
des match entre 5e et 6e et on sera
enfin notre dernier carré avec donc les
quatre joueurs qualifiés et
malheureusement les quatre éliminés sur
7 alors Paro
prendprèsir dit fou B7 il peut pas
rebondir
[Musique]
en ouais
bon comme ça je me croirais mieux avec
les Blancs moi mais bon moi aussi j'ai
un pion j'ai les fou enfin je sais pas
pourquoi ça avantage noir quand même euh
ok et euh et l'autre autre
truc qui les C5 par exemple
ouais mais tu menaces rien quoi prend 7
des 5 à
nouveau des
ouais c'est peut-être plutôt ça mais oui
c'est mieux blanc ça c'est mie encore et
B il a pris le 7 hein ok ça peut donner
une belle partie ça c'est joli ouais bon
je m'attends plus à kc5 à l'autre truc
qu'on regardait mais on verra
je pense qu'il connaît qu'il a joué
vite mais contrairement à la partie
précédente pour un truc Mme relativement
compliqué alors tu sens que ça peut
marcher mais tu peux quand même prendre
plus que 30 secondes pour le
jouerçon quand il a fait6 c'était
clairement pour ça c'est pas juste pour
prendre fait
l'enchaînement un conseil pour
progresser aux échecs bah si tu
commences tu peux acheter mon livre gag
éche et tu peux pagier peut-être d'un
cahier
d'entraînement peut-être de l'almana
aussi d'un almana les gens vont te
mettre les liens dans le chat j'imagine
je peux faire un trip si tu commences
leses échecs al ça à quel point tu es
complètement débutant le gagner aux
échecs il peut pas être de mauvais
conseil il est très très bien euh alors
forcément je l'ai pas écrit donc là tuas
tuas une belle plume dedans ah c'est
Sami qui l'a écrit hein ouais Sami qui
écrit très bien euh le C d'exercice bon
là si tuux t'exercer et faire des
exercices et cetera donc je sais pas
c'est moins pour apprendre mais c'est
pour te développer ton jeu ton calcul ta
vision tactique donc c'est important
aussi mais mais différent et a le Manac
c'est plus l'histoire un peu des échecs
des anecdotes et cetera avec quand même
des conseils et ça peut avoir l'intérêt
on va dire de faire ton truc chaque jour
de donner
une comment dire une une régularité une
petite routine et de faire un peu tes
échecs chaque jour donc ça un petit côté
sympa aussi différent voilà et quoi je
dommage de cramer cette prépa en rapide
alors je suis absolument pas d'accord
avec toi parce que c'est un des tourno
si ce n'est le tournoi il y a le plus
d'argent dans l'année en fait le seul
objectif de jouer aux échecs quand tu à
Ha niveau c'est de gagner de l'argent
bah tu te dis normalement pour moi ça ça
aa été d'être champion du monde mais vu
que j'ai l'impression que tout le monde
en a plus rien à [__] non le but c'est
de gagner du fric donc là tuas de la
cass à prendre bah tu joues ton truc
hein alors tout le monde on exagère mais
Carls s'est
retiré on voit que se qualifier ou pas
se qualifier parce que là de jouer des
trucs comme ça il iraitêre peêtre
essayer d'aller gagner des points ho
comme Dominguez ESS par exemple euh donc
fou B7 a été joué par Maxime mais écoute
je crois que c'est PL une réussite pour
alirea
l'ouverture ça
semble mais je sais pas si vous rendez
compte il quand même 200000 au vainqueur
du tournoi et on parle pas de tous les
tournois avant et tous les bonus de 1000
€ par victoire de si de là plus les
points du classement général t encore s
cas à prendre
c'est c'est
donc oui tu par comparaison je crois que
le grand chest tour en rapide c'est
40000 au premier ce qui est déjà énorme
c'est c'est un petit tournoi de 2 jours
enfin jours ah par tu compte le BIT
aussi okais 5 jours mais c'est même pas
une semaine de boulot bon mais là pour
le même temps investi c'est 5 fois plus
quoi c'est 200000 ouais c'est énorme et
après peut-être que je sais pas si le
vainqueur se qualifie pas en plus à je
sais pas si c'est ont gardé ce truc là
mais il y avait un truc de le vainqueur
et qualifieré déjà pour la F ain bah ça
je sais pas si c'est le cas là peut-être
que quelqu'un peut nous dire dans le
chat j'ai pas vérifié cette info mais si
c'est le cas c'est c'est quasiment comme
gagner le truc avec les point ou quoi
c'est peut-êre 350 K quo enfin c'est
énorme h
h donc
c'est TR de son
fouatend
après c'est dommage de griller une
prépass en plus tu perds quoi
ouais ça serait B d' rien à [__] de
faire
grand fais qu' 5 quand même jeou les
compensations qui sont pas asse
j'imagine mais qui
finance rentabilis généralement bah là
c'est sponsorisé par chessc en premier
lu puis après tu vois qu'il y a tous les
sponsors genre chess Rama et cetera
chess
B mais globalement les T d'échec c'est
très souvent c'est même quasiment tout
le temps du mesena quand même
c'est il y a pas assez de en il y a très
peu du en fait ça existe ouais ça peut
pas en fait les les sommes engagées dans
les tour d'échec sont complètement
disproportionné par RA ils font pas ça
pour que ce soit rentable on sait pas
vraiment pourqu ils font mais mais c'est
tant mieux pour les joueurs et tant
mieux pour nous fait plaisir surtout
pour les
joueurs le seul petit défaut de ça on va
dire pour le monde des échecs d'après
moi pas que d'après moi quand même il y
a pas mal de personnes influentes avec
qui j'ai parlé en fait qui pense la même
chose c'est que ça empêche absolument
tout projet normal ah bah oui en fait tu
es fermé en fait c'est ça te ferme à
double tour tu peux pas
c'est tu auras jamais de budget
suffisant pour inviter des top Mondia
c'est quasiment
impossible c'est ils sont beaucoup trop
chers par rapport au vu qui rapportte
qu'il y a trop de tournois qui qui sont
financés par du messena et des sommes
qu'on pourrait pas avoir
quoi avec du sponsoring on va dire plus
classique
ouais je sais pas MGA jou c'est rien par
rapport à ce gagent les golfeurs oui
enfin tu peux dire c'est rien aussi par
rapport à g Messi ou Mbappé ou quoi mais
tu remplis des stades au golf ouais le
GOF diffuses sur des chaînes télé
euh c'est suivi par énormement de de
téléspectateurs et cetera donc les clubs
de golf ça rapporte aussi beaucoup
d'argent il y a beaucoup ouais donc en
fait c'est tout est relatif en fonction
de tout ça en fait en fonction de tout
ça c'est faut pas regarder que l'argent
enin que combien il gagne sinon oui il
gagne moins que que d'autres mais et par
rapport au nombre de vues et tout ce que
ça implique c'est
beaucoup
mais aussi j'ai vu pass une question un
moment alors bon on vous rappelle on est
une minute de décalage par rapport à
vous donc déjens on peuent pas répondre
à tout surtout des fois si on propose un
coup ça a bougé 20 ouais en plus mais c
une question sur mais pourquoi il
gardent pas la prépa pour la finale
plutôt alors le truc c'est que là ils
sont pas très bien placés et pour qu'il
a une finale faut déjà se qualifier
avant et donc là pour lui ça c'est
important de gagner cette partie pour
rester en vie ESS de gagner ce match
euh moi je crains qu'on est quand même
un de nos deux représentants soi
éliminés avant
les de toute façon au pire ils feront 5
si et ils se rejoueront enfin ils vont
se jouer rapidement dans tous les cas il
y en a un des deux qui sera sera pas
dans le dernier carré ça c'est quasiment
sur enfin faudrait qu'il finissent trois
et ah faudrait qu'il y en a un qui
finisse 4e au moins pour avoir une
chance mais est-ce que le 3è a de viis
dans son match contre le 4e oui non tu
perd tu joues
contre en fait c'est faut être 3è ou 4e
c'est pareil ouais c'est ça 6 c'est
par en tout cas Maxim a bien réagi avec
ce fou
B7
cé le premier coup de l'ordi a jou quand
Mme assez
vite pere qui
sait cétait pas tellement une prpA cliqu
les coup sembl
logique c'est pas non
plus pe jamais savoir normalement si
c'est une PR qu' le premier coup de
l'ordi tu sais toujours ouais là en fait
il plus savoir du tout
mais je TR c'est la gestion du temps est
devenue globalement mauvaise oui depuis
les candidats ouis soit en longue en
rapide en tout il est tout le temps mal
au temps enfin mais pour rien en fait
par que des fois il t qu' perd longtemps
le joue un autre et puis retent je sais
pas ce qui lui arrive c'est bizarre non
ouais peut-être un problème de confiance
tout d'un coup dur à dire mais ouais et
c'est vrai que tu as bien raison c'est
hyper fréquent quand on ces parties
qui son t fil il y a déjà bientôt 5
minutes de retard c'est c'est beaucoup 5
minutes dans une partie de
rapide la partie d'avant on voit comment
il a perdu hein cétait ça allait bien et
puis tout d'un
coup tout d'un coup euh
ouais il s pr une petite tactique à la
fin il a finit par
perdre c'est
bizarre
c'esta mais bon du coup s'attend donc à
ce qu'il retire ce qui avait l 7 vers D5
il a pris d'abord F6 pas bê pour retirer
par la suite peut-être c'est c'est bien
joué pourquoi
pas voilà prise je pense cavalier prend
c'est
logique et sur fou prend dame prend et
c'est3 après pour
blinder blan pion après les Esser de
faire B4 et C et casser quand même tout
ça mais bon ben un pion c'est un pion
hein donc soit tour cite soit petit rock
peut-être petit rock logique je un C3
mais si ça se trouve il va faire grand
rock avec les Blancs c'est pas bê donc
peut-être tour C pour qu'il a pas grand
justement possible ouais il hésite en
tout cas
Maxime la Jae qui s'est pas encore
emballé c'est quand même une belle
position
Pr
ok j'avais pas en fait je pas j'étais
tellement pris par la tourite attaqué
que j' même pas regarder si on pouvit
faire autre chose parce que le fou
protège la tour bon ça va prendre et
prendre bah
ouais où est-ce qu'on peut donner la
dame contre les deux
toursit un peu à poil is ouais non je
pense drit TR
ouais peê une belle partie celle en
réalitéon est en train de voir pour il y
a pas d'erreur en tout cas et position
intéressante normalement qui devrait
conserver son P de
plus et
euh faire les blancs je préfère cette
pour les blancs que l'autre par que j'ai
l'impression que si tu réussis à gagner
B5 et à planter ton fou en D5 ton pion a
il va être tellement fort ah ouais ouais
il est tellement là ce
P
tellement mais tu as même une ligne
genre je sais pas j'ai une bêtise rock
euh mon fou D4 ça dame C2 fou B5 dame E4
HM qui est uneg assez logique en fait
mais tu vas [__] ton fou là en fait
j'ai l'impression que tu es vraiment
mieux ton pion est pe avancé un peu plus
fa ouais mais surtout le pion d il sert
vraiment à rien alors que le pion j'ai
l'impression que tu peux tu peux avoir
un espoir
ouais bon petit R a été
joué
fa desk 3 H1 bon ça son
cours ça suit son cours
ouaisam prend de peut-être
jouable peut-être un petit dame B7
intermédiaire pour essayer de repousser
le roi et pas laisser la tour revenir
facilement jeu en plus avec on
défendra4 plus ou c'est ça B5 qu'on a un
truc un F5 un coup pour aller ouvrir
là-bas fait quoi il fait pr pas
de c'est quoi do pas problme tu coup il
nul d
B5 tout à l'heure en
fait
il va te faire F5
après en fait ton roi est faible et le
pion ouais c'est en plus la dame on sait
pas où la mettre est un peu bloqué au
milieu de l' chiqu pas trop savoir où
aller ça pour être une belle pourit
genre de partie qu'on pourrait faire on
pret rien mais peut-être non on fera
rien du tout déjà faudrait qu'elle soit
bien jusqu'au bout mais pour l'instant
les candidates c'est la première belle
partie qu'on va jusqu'à maintenant il y
a pas vraiment d'erreur il y a une jolie
pr passe d'armes sympa position
intéressante je crois que ça joue
vraiment
bien bon prend B5 ça l'air logique quand
mêmeos merci de m'avoir permis de jouer
un grand maître après tro semaines
d'échec écoute merci à toi hein je ne
sais pas qui tu es Eagle Eagle
Albatros
je sais pas qui c'est mais il é au
tourno
j'imagine j'aimerais bien acheter t
superbe livre pour les éches où je peux
le trouver
partout
Amaz les librairies où tu veux les
boutiques ce que tu veux
partout
mais je
pense c'est quoi le
problème5 pas
facile mme si on fait coup comm4 on est
quand même plutôt mieux non for
Perre il est bien je comprends que c'est
plus
fort
al qui joue MV F rou al Maxime jouera
contre Magnus
Carlsen
contavic
est de nouveau très mal au temps sa
gestion du temps elle est vraiment après
il trouve les coups mais il trouve il
trouve tout mais gestion du temps est
particulière là dans cette partie là ça
devrait passer joue vraiment bien
mais il peut le payer quoi tu une Bane
comme la partie d'avant alors que tu
dominais et manque man un peu de
réflexion moment d'être précis pour
conclure ou quoi c'est ça le truc ouais
alors qu'il joue très
bien
mais là pour l'instant oui par immaculé
ouais pourquoi point d'interrogation
mais peut-être à cause de ce
coup5 qui pose problème en fait là le
truc c'est qu'on comprend toutes les
erfin toute la partie est logique est
très bien joué les erreurs qui sont
visuellement des coup logiques sont
réfuté de manière très précise c'est une
très jolie partie là qu'on voit je pense
qu'en fait en plus sur D F fou5 je
dirais que les Blancs ont envie de faire
fou C4 parce que de base j'aurais a bien
fait dame A7 pour mettre échec le roi et
connecter ma dame et ma tour pour
attaquer F7 mais la dame noire en C2
pourrait revenenir en C7 alors qu'avec
un fou C4 intermédiaire avant on va
attaquer F7 et on rond la connexion le
long de cette colonne C et damass 7
après pour être très problématique ou
euh enfin peu importe on met la dame
noire hor jeu
quoi
c'est
beau je sais pas peut-être que Mme
d'autres
trucs mais 5 jolis coup ouvre la
position du roi adverse pour toutes les
pièces
converg bien bien joué lon dit qu'il est
nul de ouf
il n demande si la barre blanche c'est
avantage pour allier c'est exactement ça
plus la barre blanche est haute plus
tuas de blanc dans la barre plus c'est
les blancs qui sont bien plus tu as du
noir plus c'est les noirs et quand tu
commences la partie elle est vers le 4
entre le 4 et le 5 quoi à 50 % c'est qu'
a une belle grosse barre
blanche
solide
en fait c'est logique c'est intuitif
hein de voir la barre blanche oui les
blancs sont mieux quand la barre blanche
est grande et les noirs sont mieux quand
la barre noire et grande
quoi c'est très
intuitif c'est un bot qui décide ça
exactement ouis c'est un B qui pas super
fort par contre il peut un peu se
tromper il a plutôt raison mais tu peux
pas le croire à 100 % par que tu vois il
est profondeur pas grand chose en fait
il est profondeur 22 bon et bon ça va
enfin ça donne une indication quand même
c'est quand même et là on va dire que on
ve bien le croire
quo par contre hein pour le lion juste
les joueurs pendant les parties ils ont
pas accès à ça hein c'est plus quelque
chose pour le public les
commentateurs toi tu suis sur internet
en en
navigant donc j'ai prise prise prise
alors je sais pas si fou C4 c'est si
fort ou pas mais j'y pensais al non
c'est gagnant à cause de ah mais ma 3
c'est pas dur en fait parce que faut des
6 à
tour il a raté mais pourant c'est quand
même pas très
dur et 6 FO 4 et fou
B3 su était une belle partie mais c'est
ce qu'on disait le temps
ouais c'est un peu étonnant de rater
parce que Maxim a beaucoup réfléchi
ouais le coup d'avant donc en fait tu as
bien le tempsfin tu tu savais qu' en
prendre quandême sur
5 mais fa je me questionnais si Tor
c'était chiant en fait j'avais pas de
prime à bord que j'ai vu après euh bon
on va voir c'est pas fini mais mais bon
Maxime en fait s'il a pas de problème
sur F7 il va pouvoir s'organiser cacher
son roi peut-être faire F5 à un moment
pour solidifier et euh avir 3 c'est
quand même logique en fait je pense en
partie quand même même nous même des
T b c'est logique quand même d'éloigner
le roi de en fait si tu peux amener le
roi en en E6 tu es pas mécontent quand
même non non bien sûr plus sur case
blanche
[Musique]
h on n'arrive pas à avoir de partie
euh bien de A à Z ouais
parce que mainant il y a roi 8 ouais
donc c'était tellement logique de
commencer en plus quand bien même he
dama 3 ro E6 qui est le seul coup
apparemment pour pas abandonner même si
fais fou D3 là c'est toujours une
version améliorée c'est tou une version
améliorée en fait je comprends plus de
rater fois 4 là en fait mais bon FO 4
c'est quand même logique il peut-être t
bien ou ouais c'est peut-être ça dont il
pe enfin ouais mais bon tu vas faire fou
B3 quand même non dame prend ou mais d
prend ou non bon on va gagner euh ouais
bon si do jou ça quand même envie quoi
et ça je pense pas qu'on va tenir ouais
non mais surtout si tu réussis à faire
chicchac tu vas
h non non mais ok mais c'est fou c'est
une grosse gaffe
hein après jeu demande erreur mais genre
il y en a beaucoup dans ce tournoi non
mais ce qui bizarre c'est de replomber
maintenant une fois que tu as fait ton
F3 non Maisa il y a un problème de
gestion du temps vraiment par que juste
pour sair dam C8 c'est pas le seul coup
j'imagine en plus d C7 ça va aussi ouais
ok donc c'est que ça va pas enfin s'il y
a vraiment un coup que tu as pas vu euh
le seul coup qui peut te gêner en fait
c'est fout 6 mais F 6 tour c'est fin de
variante instanté il y a pas de suite on
prend le fou au coup
d'après hyper étonnant comme faute mais
c'est vraiment comme ENF on se répète
mais c'est la c'est même pas la faute
qui est bizarre c'est vraiment la
gestion du temps
ouis D 3 maintenant ro 8 donc oui le roi
M 8
aès il a pas senti que c'était le moment
en fait j'ai son qui tu sa plus qu'
réfléchir ouais c'est ça c'est qu'il a
un problème
de sensation sur le momentum quoi je
trouve c'est un truc qui se retrouve
quand même beaucoup dans ses parties je
rappelle la partie qu'il a pas gagné
contre domingaz où il était pas loin
d'être gagnant il s mis mal autant
enfin il a quand même un peu trop
réfléchi avant le moment décisif et
après voilà il se retrouve dans moment
décisif il a plus que mais tu as
quelques secondes après bon ben
évidemment avec peu de secondes c'est
dur de trouver toujours les bons coupsoi
tu cliques au hasard même si c'est une
très bonne intuition tu vas en trouver
plusieurs et puis à un moment c'est à
côté bon ben il a joué dame 4 mais le
roi va partir se cacher comme si R quoi
ouais Maxim a plus besoin de nul ouais
exactement
mais en fait si c'était
le par que Max partie précédente alira
avait aussi réussi à défendre mais alira
avait 15 secondes contre 3 minutes que
si on avait de nouveaux la solution
inverse il a quand même réussi à
défendre mais il se retrouve avec 15 5
minutes pour ala et 10 secondes pour
Maxime encore de vraie chance on voit
que en fait s gère mal ouais il gère mal
son
temps en de Bwin à la partie d'avant
stunt parti ouais c'était assez n ouis
et là finalement on était proche d'avoir
jolie partie
finalement le souffl c'est
effondré
sur pe y
[Musique]
aller mais ai en
fait encore mieux plus
simple il y a plus d'attaque contre ce
roi noir il s'est
caché et en plus on Arve pas à faire à 4
ou
quoi il y a plus d'avantage du tout en
fait pour les blancs
ouais mais on l'a pas notre première
très belle
partie la sera pas analysé
mal je pense
pas on analysera à partir
de des matchs couperés peut-être ou si
Maxime fait une belle partie contre
Magnus ça peut être cool
ça notre classico à nous notre classico
à nous surtout que ça va être un match
important quand même parce que Maxime
peut peut-être encore rêver d'une 4e
place s' gagne les deux derniers matchs
c'est vrai qu'il y a deux joueurs qui
carac en tête après c'est assez serré
c'est pour ça
ouis ça serait beau de finir 4e malgré
la défite contre la zavic et sa aussi
c'est dommage il avait tellement en main
non mais ouais enin cono il doit gagner
vu le contenu mais tu te dis bon perd to
ça peut arriver mais la zavic tu
t'attends jusquelle fasse zéro sur
l'épreuve et c'est ce qui lui éit arrivé
jusque là et donc on peut être un peu
ouais
déçu et on il peutre nous en du petit H5
Maxime pour
aller taper un peu vers le RO adverse en
tout cas les r faudra pas qu'il rate la
zavic hein
pas à l'erreur pas du tout sinon c'est
tour probablement de victoires je pense
pas que ça
suffise je pense TR victoires tu fais 5
6 et 4 victoires ture une chance de
faire 3 4
quoi peut-être autre joueur je trouve
pas très en mais qui ame marqué quelques
mois c'est que j'allais
dire
mais
il est
payé Raz qui essae de de pas trop
échanger les pièces mais qui qui trouve
rien faire de spécial dans la position
H4 maintenant et voilà ouais c'est ça
ouais mais il a tellement
régressé incroyable gen tu reconnais
ement pas genre de Top 3 4 mondial de la
cadence c'est peut-être top 30
maintenant
enfin dem 3 défense à
tour des de
aussi je sais pas si va ex un petit
G5 il est pas obligé hein lui il peut
faire que nul doncil peut passer son
tour là l'Amn c'est bien joué il
repartir en A3 ou attendre
quoi vir en D4
voà bon il fait ce qu'il veutame des4
très bien on fait un petit chantage à
l'échange de
damea serait pas un des joueurs qui a le
plus régressé pe dame des6 retour depuis
un
an bah après je sais pas
euh bon en tout cas il a régressé ça on
est d'accord le le truc c'est quel était
son niveau réel quand il était numéro 2
mondial en fait il est monté comme une
fusée
mais il jouit quand même mieux que ça ah
non mais il jouait mieux enfin quand il
a fait 8 et à la Coupe d'Europe enfin
champion d'OPE des nations c'est
extraordinaire commeulta après il jouait
pas les top top joueurs mais quand il
jou ça se passait pas mal enfin je pense
c'était bien payé d' numéro de mondial
mais il avait un truc dans le jeu et euh
que maintenant même les plots il les
écras plusou c'est ça il a perdu ce truc
qu'il avait aller
massacré
bref mais bon bien sûr c'est aussi
histoire d'investissement et motivation
tout ça mais c'est vrai qu'il fout le
flop en fait
hein mais c'est un peu la raison pour
laquelle c'est toujours dur de de se
prononcer sur les jeunes joueurs tu sais
pas trop ce qu'il vont faire de leur vie
et tout ça quoi euh en fait c'est vra
que j'ai j'ai j'ai l'impression que les
échecs c'est quand même quelque chose
que beaucoup de gens aiment enfant et
puis après adultes même s'ils sont très
forts c'est quand même un jeu qui plaît
pas trop quoi prof j'ai l'impression que
quand
tu ça fait entre guillemets chier les
[Musique]
jouis la petite nul tout
échanger Maxime qui g ce match gros
danger pour la suite
me
juste va pas va perdre
peut-être on peut aller voir Carl sa il
y a de nul il y a un Armon ah bah voilà
on a quand même un petit arme àon on
était proche de pas avoir d'arme à
Guedon parce que ikaro ah car qui est
peut-être en train de de flancher de
flancher
ouais il fautu non là il a pas l'air
bien ouais ben on voit la
cam tout
sourire carou qui s'il perd il se
retrouve très en danger aussi on fair le
standings on va peut-être regarder le
match di carou en fait hein parce parce
que Maxim on voit qu'il a gagné son
match donc lui il passe devant et carou
il a une victoire ah oui c'est que si
Abdou le bat Abdou passe à TR victoires
ouais très mal carou qui qui doit qui
doit gagner pour pour rester dans ce
tourno intéressant de voir TU Maxime si
va Magnus en fait il est pas si mal bon
après Carana va gagnerà trois
victoiresbe peut aussi être à tro
victoires mais en fait à trois
victoires
vous êtes dur on parle des meilleurs
joueurs du monde régression c'est fort
bah écoute si tu étais numéro 1 mondial
et tu es numéro 5 mondial tu ras
régressé en fait je va donner un autre
exemple parle tu es 1200 aujourd'hui tu
passes 1400 1200 c'est faible tu passes
100 tu as fait une progression même si
tu es faible tu progresses si tu étais
par exemple Nadal il a régressé au
tennis depuis un an et demi au
classement ouais au classement même dans
le je j'imagine bien
ouais je pense que MRO aujourd'hui joue
moins bien qu' au tennis enfin non mais
oui je pens peut être le meilleur et
régresser serait pas insulte à Boris
Pasky dire qu'il est moins fort que pour
son match contre Fisher enfin non non
bah oui non mais c'est dur de dire les
choses maintenant si tu es pas en full
pépon tout le temps de tout de c'est que
c'est que tu as le seum et que tu es
toxique mais mais là il y a rien de
méchant en fait ENF c'est factuel mais
il était numéro 2 mondial là quand tu
vois jouer tu as plus l'impression qu'il
est top 25 top 30 il a perdu 60 points
lo depuis qu'il rejoue sur 6 mois donc
c'est pas une bonne phase ça veut pas
dire qu'il peut pas inverser les choses
peut-être plus tard
ou ou bien se reprendre ou quoi mais
mais bon quand es sur les classement la
pente elle fait
ça pas la progression qu progression
c'est
ça et ça joue encore un côté laavana on
pas j'ai enlevé les noms parce que c'est
on aurait pas pu tout mettre bien au bon
moment en tout cas va tenir la nul et
donc qui va gagner son
match ano qui a fait le taf donc on pe
le classement qui d être remis à jour
avant les arm mais donc
enc victoir
etjoindre pour peutêtre exactement allez
à tout de
suite air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things a new opening for your wall is
here capture new major pieces on unique
metal posters from displate now with the
official collection from Chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolfe magnet kit
and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal poersop now with the code
displate.com
[Musique]
ch
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hop ça repart les amis
camura contre
parlsen mais contre Abdou satorf mince
je me suis encore trompé je su à chaque
fois on va voir le temps Fab et oui donc
déjà premier gros gros intérêt c'est
savoir la
pendule Abdou donc qui a les blancs il a
perdu
le les enchr
ench il a pris 9 minutes
bon refa pas la même quoi juste quoi il
ref
il fait pas la même bah au moins il se
prend pas qu' G4 sur F 3 mais c'est pas
connu comme étant un truc bien de jouer
K
2 ils ont pas de prépa contre la
calach mais il
retanque bon on va voir hein je sais pas
je peux pas trop dire je comprends pas
juste mais
surtout qu'en plus si ça t'a trop embêté
la calage tu peux faire trois fou B5
hein enfin ou ou n'importe quoi en fait
mais non je suis un peu étonné
là non mais en fa tu peux pasavoir les
blanc et te reprendre une prépa enfin tu
vois te prendre des prépas à chaque fois
quoi
is peut-êre fou G5 pour Chloé bon sinon
c'est sûr qu'il y a absolument
rien c'est hyper
étonnant surtout qu'il est parti avec
son truc de cavalier 2 genre il avait
vraiment une idée de faire enfin c'est
comme si ça voulu éviter les prépas et
peut-être pourquoire deux trois coup de
plus que son adversaire mais je veux
dire là c'est même pas le cas
bon car qui est
serein on
verin comment ne pas
l'être il est
William comment ne pas
l'être
c ça réfléchi côé Abdou bon ça su quoi
j'ai
[Musique]
l'impression entre fou G5 et mais c'est
F G5 je comprends le problème par qu' do
pe qu' prendre des TR d' prend D3 fa
prend
F2
et5 prend D3 faire c prend
c'est une sele gueule et ne pas faire
fou G5
[Musique]
B bizarre
aussi donc il
su ok du coup ben il va PIR reprendre en
D5 avec les Noirs donc jouit pas avant
bien évidemment parce qu'il y avait un
FPR H7 qui traîit avec une dame en l'air
mais là maintenant bien sûr il est bien
assez en nombre pour pouvoir reprendre
ce pion D5 avec l'un cavalier ou avec
l'autre c'est comme il
veut jeis pas le B me SEM plus logique
intuitivement mais
bon va pas changer
grand-chose c'est incroyable quand même
c'est ouvertur parfois c'est
surprenant il a pris du F
ouais après je peux comprendre aussi sur
le fou
donc on va peut-être pas avoir une belle
partie on l'attend notre première belle
partie du tournoi on l'attend on avait
espoir sur
celle-là mais je crois que ça va être
encore raté on n pas passé loin dans la
précédente dal
Reza
bon ouais cétait pas loin faire all r la
partie d'avant il manqué un dame à 3
ouais non là Abdou il rate complètement
sa partie c'est un truc de ouf par qu'il
a déjà 4 minutes il a fait
ne mais bon ce qui de franchement enfin
une F en arme surprise pourquoi pas mais
je comprends pas
quoi Maxime une fois m' joué ça en 2000
je sais pas quoi
7 donc une fois quoi c'est la seule fois
de ma vie où j'ai vu ce coup
mais mais d'ailleurs ouais je vais
regarder récemment là comme j'ai fait du
j'ai fait une série de vidéo dessus bah
ça m'a toujours pas r impressionné quoi
donc
euh je comprends même pas où est l'ID
des blanc
quoi c'est bizarre hein mais c'est
dommage que ça donne pas des belles
parties du coup non mais là c'est 100 %
de sa faute hein enfin s'il perd ce
match comme
ça on verra il va avoir une partie qui
joue bon justement c'est pas pourquoi tu
as les blancs quoi
mais jou il vaendre prend d prend et F5
peut-être encore plus fort
ouaisv la partie est nulle quoi oui oui
mais
B pas nul direct mais mais tu vas jamais
gagner c'estossible bah non en tu es pas
mieux après bien sûr si les Noirs se
mettent à mal jouer ou quoi on sait
jamais mais en
soi
après comprenez bien on est plutôt déçu
parce que c'est enfin c'est comme si on
voit des mauvais matchs quoi on a envie
de voir des belles parties et d'un peu
vibrer là c'est des parties qui sont
quand même très
insipides on va voir allez il va pousser
sa majorité l' dame
et qui
c'est
sur les parties rapides il y a forcément
des Bunder c'est parti vous plaignez de
la cadence on peut pas tout
avoir il y a pas de lunder en fait non
mais je sens que CELI qui dit ça
donc Piral Dubi doit pas trop comprendre
le propos en fait donc les parties
lentes quand sont trop lentes ben oui
des fois tu attends pour rien là c'est
pas du blunder c'est que tu joues de la
merde après c coups d'ouverture c'est
par ce que j'appelle un blunder quoi
blunder ça serait s'il faisait des
gaffes ici ou là et bon quand en a eu
parle dans la partie der contre Maxime
on n pas dit ah non la partie c'est de
la merde par a des blenders c'était
juste toute façon le contenu avant qui
allait pas donc a des gaffes en fin de
partie pourquoi pas c'est même pas le
propos
mais mais là en fait c'est son choix
d'ouverture qui va
pas estce qu' a d'incompréhensible c'est
qu'il a déjà fait ce choix là dans la
partie d'avant dans la partie d'avant
triikarou donc il a il y a une heure de
ça une partie qu' a quand même perdu les
clés blancs déjà bon bah là tu as une
deuxième chance parce qu' il s'est
imposé les clés noir mais il refait la
même mais je sais pas quoi dire en fait
c'est donc bon ça veut pas dire que
peut-être il va pas gagner mais c'est
c'est incroyable de ça avec les Blancs
d'avoir bientôt moins de temps que ton
adversaire tu es parti avec 6 minutes
d'avance à la
pendule B ça va pas en fait qu'est-ce
que je te dis je vais pas dire waouh
trop génial bravo qui a li de et la
vente qu' a joué quoi pas si tu veux je
le dis bravo voilà mais
c'est dommage ça donne pas une partie
spectaculaire parce que du coup les
noirs qui ont besoin que de faire nul
hein dans l' magedon c'est la
règle et donc il se fait complètement
sécher la part a pas de pas de de de
saveur non mais bon
après comme je t' dit peut-être qu'il y
a quand même finir pour gagner parce que
bah justement il y a une connerie
d'ikarou à un moment ou je ne sais quoi
ça peut mais euh il sera pas aller la
chercher par la qualité de son jeu
quoi
pour l'instant ikarou ne lâche pas la
proie pas d'erreur ça a l'air hyper
facile bon il a envie de faire G6 F5
s'il peut oner sa propre majorité monter
son roi et
cetera
des7
bon je crois qu'il va les changer
celle-là faire tour des8
probablement pourquoi il a joué ça en
armagadon ben il sa ouais non je sais
pas là c'était vraiment n'importe
quoi
les blancs et si vite moins de temps
ouais surtout c'est moins de temps et
parti complètement raté quoi bah il pas
de chance de gain parceen plus clou donc
il va devoir faire fou G4 pour repartir
bah ça va encore échanger donc il aura
même plus de tour sur les
chiqu aès bon ben il tente on va
[Musique]
voir c'est dommage parce qu'on
s'attendait à avoir un gros combat
d'avoir un un Abdou qui envoieine et un
et un nikarou qui
défend bienible de proposer autant
d'échan ouais mais là je crois qu'in il
a tellement raté son ouverture que il
avait pas le choix il le subit en fait
ça mais c'est pour ça qu'on était pas
content de l'ouverture en fait c'était
pas tu déjà compris que le enfin le SC
de la partie était écrit sur du papier
de verre quoi mais bon ben écoute
après voilà bah il va essayer de tourner
en rond et de je sais pas attendre
espérer une une bourde en face
maisquement plus AGR à jouer au blanc
non ça
non
c'est juste nul en fait non par en fait
souvent ce qu'il doivent vouloir penser
c'est que un fou c'est mieux qu'un
cavalier quand tu a des P sur les deux
ailes problème c'est que là ta majorité
tu vas pas avancer bien loin avec même
si tu fais C4 C5 bon ben même tu arveras
pas en plus et euh ton roi il est pas
plus actif et fait tu as pas vraiment
d'argument à faire Valir avec impression
que si jamais tu dois vraiment tenter de
gagner c'est plus facile avec le
cavalier qui peut tour si tu veux la
forcer je veux dire si tu dois
forcer et et voilà donc en fait
disons symboliquement ça ça pourrait
être mieux pour les blancs si le P C3
était en F peut-être un truc symétrique
ton ramonte et encore je vois pas
comment mais mais
là merci
François non mais ouais moi jeisf si je
devais jouer le gain je prendrai les
Noirs donner le
choix même inagnable aussi
[Musique]
mais
qui monte son
roi36 et mant il va essayer
de de rester comme ça quoi dans la pas
pour gagner G34 c'est
faire ça les quandme mais
ouaas jamais C5 en
fait
est-ce conentr pas fou des5 7
C4 et
après RET des TR machin et passer
là-bas bah faut tenter des choses comme
ça de toute façon il peut pas juste
faire nul sans rien faire
donc à
voir bon 5 minutes chacun et on
verra
faire roi E3 tu peux faire H4
G3 après essayer de rentrer
quoi le seul truc à mon avi qui peut lui
permettre de jouer un peu le gain c'est
que si noir je vraiment que enfin trop
passif trop
passif et loulin normalement tu peux pas
jouer les recoposer sur la calach c'est
pas c'est pas une Sicilienne qui te
permet de jouer comme
ça la partie enfin c'était la chevche
qu'on avait vu de NPO contre Maxime
Dison ça peut arriver une fois de temps
en temps sur une r précise et une
configuration bon mais c'est pas le
scénario auquel tu t'attends je sais pas
si tu avais vu la partie max très belle
partie
Dean je pense je D voir mais sont très
très bien
joué en rapide il a gagné très
facilement mais c'était prépa
h et c'était une jeevche et pas une
calache mais bon comme il y a des
transpositions ouais ça se ressemble en
ouverture cisine c'est pas tout à fait
pareil
mais mais euh il fait ce qu'il faut là
tu vois quand il joue pas trop passif il
fait fait il fait des choses
je me disais juste si tu stand stand en
fait ça peut commencer à mal tourner
qui VI défendre ses
pions après seul petit truc où tu es
content c'est qu'il a quand même mis ses
pions sur blanc
ouais après là si car il perd ça c'est
après c'est pas forcément le même homme
en réel ou sur Internet il est moins
tranchant en
3D
ouais qui nous impressionne tellement
dans
résultates en
gagnant plus qu'un sur de même en fait
non un peu moins depuis quelques
semaines quand vraiment affuté il en
gagner
sur incroyableo vraent un plateau de fou
quoi voir ultra dominant alors là bon il
va peut-être se qualifier ou il su quoi
il a jamais gagné un championnat du
monde de blit rapide après en 15 15 en
15 ans quoi donc alors c'est aussi fort
qu'un ouais forcément beaucoup plus dur
quoiend qu' en a déjà 6 ou 7 dans son
escarcel de rapide ouais ou même les
deux mais non il a passage la 3D à la 2D
pas forcément
facile
Abdou par rapport à ce qu'il a
eu par rapport à son ouverture il
pouvait pas espérer mieux que ce qu'il
est en train d'avoir maintenant ouais
bon ce qui pass St
mais on dit que Magnus est dans le dur
contre West peut-être une bonne nouvelle
pour Maxime comme ça s bat Magnus il
pourrait
même le rattraper Mme sil est quand même
très très
loin bon c'est en tout cas qu' fait son
tournoi
lui je un juste comme ça Magnus pour
voir ah ouais c'est il ser enfin je
pense qu'ils sont tous les deux 1 et de
quasiment sûr mais bon du coup là cette
victoire là oh il G4 ah c'est bien joué
ça il veut le cavalier un
peu genre C prend ro G3 G5 x 4 ouais r
F6 C4 et C G6 bouff bouf c'est5 je
reviens dans le carré
pourtant écoute mais peut-être tu peux
faire c C4 A4 C5 B5
A5 qu'est-ce qu'ils disent bah non ah
mais soit est blanc ok oui mon soit est
beaucoup mieux oui une de plus quoi euh
ouais il va gagner
çaouer l'autre HM ouais devrait
gagner après prier deè ça ne change rien
mais là G5 bien joué de la part carou
ouais il veut pas se faire fixer avec
des pions sur blanc
ou il aurait fallu avoir le temps de
jouer G5 avec les Blancs pour vraiment
obtenir un avantage
peut-être bizarre de pas l'avoir fait à
ce momentl il avit pas le temps ça
B5
parti assz terne mais bon après bon
bonne défense du carou pour l'instant il
a bien jouer
hein après Abdou c'est un des joueurs
les
plus fort en arnaque il av gag
championat du monde de rap
tout que c'est un des c'est son talent
en fait
d'arnaquer et aussi je pense qu'il est
travailleur comme comme joueur
ouais mais il a un peu marqué le pas en
longue dernièrement mais après c'est
peut-être une saison de transition pour
lui après c'est pas facile hein de jouer
de toujours des monstre je pense que
tous les joueurs ont quand même ce
problème les joueurs actuels ont quand
même ce problème sauf pour les joueurs
indiens d'ailleurs qui l'ont moins mais
à l'Arée là à 18 ans
euh je crois qu'il découvre d'autres
plaisirs de la vie h et que du coup
rester enfermé 10h à regarder un plateau
ils comprennent que comme il y a pas ils
commencent quer bien leur vie ils ont
accès à d'autres tu vois et j'ai
l'impression que
ça que ça joue négativement en fait
sur les résultats parce qu'avant il y
avait tellement moins d'argent dans les
échecs to tu avais 18 ans bah tu es
obligé de faire à fond tu obligé de
continuer à fond puis de toute façon bon
2000 balles par mois si tu passes h 24
chez toi enfermé tu vas pas enfin tu as
pas accès à grand chose quoi là quand tu
commences à gagner des 400 500000 € mais
pour pas faire grand chose en plus rest
chez toi en plus maintenant tu as même
besoin de te
déplacer il y a peut-être des activités
qui te prennent du temps mais là il
c'est bien ce par qu'il a foutu mal au
temps mais ikaro il est vraiment moins
dominant en réel que sur Internet hein
il y a rien à dire genre sur internet je
voiris jamais suer là il y a peut-être
C5 pu on prend et puis on oui des trucs
comme ça on sait
pas je crois que tu t'en sors que tu vas
réussir à toucher la case à 7 et tu vas
faire un blocus mais je tu sens qu'il
est tellement moins William sin du coup
peutêtre C5 puis on prend puis on prend
prend C5 chasser le cavalier
rentr4 c'est5 maintenant à quoi je
pensais
D3 bizarre de fait C5 le faire tu peux
pas laisser arriv
quoi
ali4 attaer
g4on mais là avec très peu de temps la
pendule on peut voir des
Dinger tu fais quoi je
[Musique]
pas reviens par là
d5re scch un défense du pion mais c'est
incroyable ce qu'il a fait
Abdou
ça ferme par contre
C6 franchement ça peut mal
tourner
G64 et recour après Leong ave le
cavalier incroyable
il va y arriver je
pense mais 44 secondes il y a du rajou
que à partir du 60e il y a encore 13
coup à
jouer
5 D6 il se replace il se G5 en stock
pour les ver 4 peut-être un moment ça va
être son piège entre gu piège ça doit
être son coup un peu et a dit que
c'était gagnant à un moment mais là on
sait pas trop mais F c'est hyper bien
joué parce qu' dépend les de pions et il
est gagnant
incroyable bah disons en fait la nvelle
pour c'est que le pion cas est BL
on va voir réuss à terminer
Abdou ce
soit faire CP après de Mar pour
mettre la
position
coupess de faire no en
fait ouais mais il a plus de
temps fou
B5 fait fou de c'est
6 il ok bah il a plus ou moins fait ça
en
fait7 F7
ouais alors peut-être ça all jouer avec
les une seconde par coup ouais donc ça
va plus
tomber pas sûr encore hein c'est chaud
c'est chaud de bonne
chance c'est chaud parce qu'il y a plus
de temps c'est
ça voà ce crois que c'est bien ce qu'il
fait B il se rapproche son ro il va y
arriver
ouais ro B6 il peut prendre ouais et
maintenant il met le fou en D1 il cache
et il gagne il va retourver sur la case
magique et ça su côté ikarou incroyable
d'avoir perdu ça mais incroyable he il
est beaucoup moins dominant en réel
ouais ouais ouais sur Internet j'aurais
jamais vu perdre ça c'est incroyable de
perdre cette finale il aurait pr mové en
plus ouais il aurait fait nul sans aucun
problème perdre cette finale c'est juste
criminel comme dirait Vlad mais j'ai pas
aimé G6 déjà de base mais bon après ça
ouais bon ça peut faire une belle vidéo
quoie comme il est
con je sais même pas comment ça s'est
passé en fait comment il a pu perdre et
là je crois qu'il y a un moment critique
là il a K C5 qui faisait vraiment nul
mais
bon déjà plus mais ton roi il passe pas
ouais ouais mais roi des ah roi des4 roi
D6 ouais
ais mais tu sens qu'en fait ah tu dois
calculer pour faire
[Musique]
mais et euh et che Magnus est-ce qu'il a
perdu juste pour savoir incroyable qu'il
est perdu quand même ikarou je suis
impressionné ouais a perdu d'ailleurs ah
ben ikarou en gros dange pe se faire
éliminer il est encore
ré4 F5 et
C3 il sur fou 8 je pense tu suis ah tu
suisou ah il a fait beaucoup de gaffe en
fait bien joué Abdou franchement on y
croyait pas on a été mauvaise
langue bon son ouverture restit pas ouf
quand même
il a joué longtemps
et est moins de moins dominant moins
comment dire moins fringant c'est vrai
qu'on a on a moins bon hein voilà sur
sur les chitiers là que ce qu'on a pu
voir récemment et qui a perdu donc au
classement ça nous donne West leso en
tête avec cinq victoires en 5 matchs
Magnus qui vient de perdre qui a quatre
qui va jouer contre Maxim Abdou satov 3e
avec carwana ils sont quand même bien
embarqués Maxime en embuscade euh qui
rêve de battre Magnus euh et après euh
entre ikarou firou il y en a un des deux
qui va passer à la trappe j'imagine hein
normalement c'est la place qui lui est
réserv
dernière contre
l'autre j'ai du
[Musique]
malimaginerimin rap mais bon écoute à
jouer je sais pas je peux regarder
trouav quand
même
je suppose qu'il lui reste
laavic kwana je
pense je crois qu'il a déjà ah mais je
sais
pas je peuxir qu'il a déjà joué en fait
on faire pasélimination alors il a joué
qui regarde son parcours ronde 1 il perd
contre ronde 2 il perd contre Maxime
rond 3 il
Batou rond 4 il perd Agnus R 5 hy per
Abdou donc il reste carwana tu as raison
et carlen et euh et lazavic c'est ça
j'avais euh ouais donc il reste quand
même favori parce qu'il a un bon matchup
contre carwana HM mais si per là contre
carwana il sera en énorme danger ça peut
arriver bon les amis pause c'est la pose
mérité et on revient vers 45 je pense
exactement pour le choc quand même
Carlsen
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors les amis on va être parti pour
pour le match les joueurs qui sont en
train d'arriver on a
Carana là on a laavic etou avec son joli
P à 400 350 €
on a l'information et on a Maxime donc
contre Magnus le
classico Magnus qui les blanc pour cette
première
parti bien AC les Noirs touj un peu
mieuxour à
domicile peux forcer
on en peut parler entre les parties avec
Maxime juste
là je d que résultat du car é
intéressant il m'a écrit
important les gens sont contents de mon
tweet en réponse à
Booba ah ce serait
beau je crois que si Booba veut faire
des échecs je suis la meilleure personne
qui existe pour faire une collab ah
c'est sûr ouis je crois que là il peut
pas y avoir mieux au
monde score c'est 00 par contre je vois
qu'on a pas le bon
score
qui nous écrit 350 € c'est plus que tout
mon outfit de Sami et moi
aussi mais ma femme dit toujours que
quand tu as du goût tu as pas besoin
d'avoir trop d'argent pour
t'habiller ça veut tout
dire
prends la dernière fritre elles sont pas
malogr c'est pas mal pour les frites ou
la
vutre pas mal ces aérogris frayur là je
sais pas comment ça
s'appelle
a priori pas mal point santé déjà mais
le goût est très bien c'est onctueux
ouais un cô
oncueux c'est parti F3 joué par Magnus
D5 C4 et qu'est-ce que joue Maxim D4
sûrement je dirais mais bon on va
voir parce que des praner bon si faire
accep çaa du sens mais non normalement
c'est plutôt une bonne version pour les
blancs avec E3 faut prendre C4 et cetera
tu es pas obligé de jouer avec D4 s fait
C6 ou E6 bah Magnus pourra jouer D4 et
trans dans un grandidame normal ce qui
est pas dans l'appartoire de Maxime donc
je m'attends à D4 est le seul coup
indépendant quelque part
ou C6 pour jouer une slave oui mais
justement ça le sort enfin
ouais mais il les joue un peu non ouais
mais moi fe mais c'est bizarre c'est
bizarre euh donc là Magnus sais pas ce
qu'il est en tête s'il veut faire G3
pour jouer une catalane ben voilà mais
peut-être D4 il aurait pu faire F6 fou
G2 j'imagine et sur fou 7 il va
probablement jouer D4 pour jouer une une
catalane ou il veut roquer B3 et jouer
la la bon qu' une reti quoi moi je
jouais B3 ici en général mais D4 et bah
juste la Catalane normale que
normalement Carlsen connaît très bien
quoi et que je jouerais vu
[Musique]
le dans sa situation j'ai envie de dire
et là j
B3 le coup que je joue avant mais comme
je te dis que j'aurais pas joué là à sa
place donc B3 bah il y a plein
complètement à côté quoi B enfin c'est
lui qui est à côté sûrement
ou euh C5 est le coup classique des
Noirs apr tu peux faire
B6 il il fait des qu maintenant alors
euh ça là il y a une suite à la mode ah
c'est pas3 enfin il pourra le faire
c'est C 5 qui des3 pour faire
F4 V une partie de ouf de Ding contre
Guiry vishkandzi je sais pas si ça te
dit un truc avec ça et sur E3 bon ben
c'est 5 en général D3 tu vas te le faire
croquer ahouis non D3 tu peux
pas c'est pire que son F6 d'IER c'est
pour
dire non en général c'est c'est5 qui
après eux décédé c'est une bénonie
inversée quoi et on dit dommage que vous
ayez totalement focus sur la parti car
tout à l'heure alors que Magon de so
était magnifique le truc c'est qu'on a
focus sur la partie en jeu en
fait puisque so Carlsen quelque part
l'en jeu était moindre la partie
d'ikarou elle est importante parce
qu'ikarou est au bord du précipice quand
même C6 de
Maxime bon je pense au faire prendre je
sais
pas bon je pense que ce qu'il veut sur F
B2 il ve faire E5 al l'ordi aime pas à
cause de Ed cavalier prend fou B2 bon
c'est 5 je pense ou je vois pas pourquoi
ça va pas en
fait c'est pas ça c'est juste bon les
blancs vont échanger une pièce mineure
ils sont plutôt conten mais tu peux pas
trop empêcher que ça
arrive priori ce que je
ferais B quand même je pense c'est
logique prend après ah mais ça va en
fait ve 5 c'est ça ouais c'est ça ouais
donc prise c'est logique pour moi ça
c'est logique ouais et là bon là faut
voir est-ce que K C3 est-ce que fou B2
c'est5 et je prends quand même mais j'ai
changé une pièce
légère alordi va pas du tout de C5 dans
son range oui mais mais dans débile coup
normal en fait tu le fais pas avec T
Chang en F3 les blans on faire des4
prendre tout le sens ouais donc tu veux
pas donc c'est 5 faut faire is ou bon F
C5 admettant peut-être il mettre le P en
C6 peut-être mais ouais ok je comprends
pourquoi les blancs sont mieux tu V
mettre le
cavali5 cavalier A3 peut-être aussi
ouaisas quand même ce vis-àis pénible
mais il a vraiment pasvie jouer C5
Maxime mais qui devait aller ici
j'imagine mais comm je te dis les blanc
échangeras une de Benon couleur inversée
évidemment et o tuas échangé une pièce
légère tu es plutôt content
la attends est-ce qu'il y a pas un
paramètre
pour
c'est quoi ce truc téléchargement 45
MB on risque peut-être tu télécharger un
truc pour que le truc soit fort je sais
pas un truc est nul en tout
cas après moi ça me dérange pas d'avoir
un truc complètement nul
hein comment on
réfléchit en fait le truc c'est qu'il y
a aucune profondeur enfin
c'est profondeur 20 quoi c'est vrai que
ça aucun intérêt
ouais il voit les petites tactiques en
de enin gen à ce niveau-là de jeu dans
une position si compliquée profondeur 20
il peut avoir
vraiment un delta d'erreur qui est
énorme je ser bien si j' quelqu'un chaud
notamment durant l'attaque de mat oui
bon écoute frérot enfin fais ton stream
en fait non mais je sais pas comment
dire en fait et on a toujours fait comme
ça on regarde une partie en grand format
et puis après on vient voir ce qui se
passe on peut pas voir deux parties en
même temps déjà une on a du mal deux on
su hein non en plus le truc c'est que tu
peux plus facilement faire ça si tu as
quelqu'un qui regarde les parties à côté
et qui dit dans le tiens V si va là-bas
bon ben on n pas de de régim quand même
ou même ça ça marche pas j'ai Ludvig en
backup mais tu arrives pas ENF
BUP c'est dur il y a beaucoup de monde
là bonah tu as deux pars oui mais fa
Magnus un truc ça sert à rien bah ça
sert à rien bon
façon tu arrives PAF ah bah ça y est il
est une d de MO quoi bon benah voilà il
une dame de MO oui mais du coup tu as
Comand m perdu le moment thème d'abdous
qui a quand même gagné du coup on a vu
qu'il a gagné à partir de rien enfin
mais le truc c'est qu'en fait
normalement la plupart des gens ont
beaucoup de mal à suivre une partie al
deux en même temps et ou trois ou
quatre partout là c'est c'est c'est trop
compliqué non mais je veux dire autre
chose par moi le rugby je déteste quand
ils font le multiplex je vois jamais le
match tu vois jamais match voilà tu vois
des actions je déteste tu vois les
belles actions mais je m'en fiche si tu
veux tu vas faire des résum Youtube pour
ça mais j'ai pas le leing du match pas
leing du match ouais un bel ESS mais
c'est pas mais bon tu sais que
maintenant pour beaucoup c'est trop
compliqué de un match de foot parce
c'est trop long oui non mais fa que 10
secondes là mais jeux bien mais gen en
fait c'est mais en fait si tu aimes bien
le foot tu tu aimes bien le foot c'est
pas pour regarder 10 secondes je suis
d'accord avec toi en
fait k C3 l'ordi aime pas par exemple
mais c'est vraiment logique al il aime
pas à cause d'un truc très logique par
contre c'est cavalier prend fou prend il
fout des ça me fait penser au truc à
l'envers
des
dans les catalan F F5 ah 44 pour te
mettre en vis-avis dans les GR les
machins je vois mais là c'est la même
chose tu viens le coller quoi Mar marage
à la
culotte moi je pense que Maxime il peut
battre Magnus fait je pense que Maxime
c'est le pire matchup de
Magnus prendre la dame je pense pas du
Fou
tu F def oui oui mais bon tu fais tour à
D1 A4 tu fais rien en fait oui mais je
te faire tour B8 B6 F B7 c'est en voilà
on échange tout
quoi mais c'est marrant parce que si
c'est avec l'autre cavalier c'est hyper
facile à trouver bon là ça va c'est
trouvable non mais genre le F5 FRC 3
enfin on a trop l'habitude de le faire
non c'est V que c'est pas truc fréquent
mais qui tu vois du coup ça vient moins
vite au cerveau après une fois que tu as
vu le coup et tu dis oui mais en fait
c'est juste la même chose symétriquement
ça devient hyper facile mais plusurs d'
pens tu vois il a pas trouvé du coup
mais genre c'est marrant h
l'essionession il aurait été juste
renversé symétriquement il aurait trouvé
sans
problème
après peut-être qu' att tend cavalier A4
et pour faire c pr F3 il f
D4 sauf que tu es pas obligé de faire C
4 maintenant tu peux faire 5 Caval 4 ou
mais en plus tour 8 appelle
cavaler5 Maxim F longtemps la bête noire
de Magnus bête noire j'aurais pas
appeler le mot bête noire dans le sens
où Magnus bon il a quand même beaucoup
plus de victoire que Maxime mais mais
c'est un joueur qui le G historque c'est
pasque en tout
cas onis sur le head to head sur les
dernières années Abdou un TR matchup
pour lui pour Maxime ouais mais il y a
pas mal le parti internet en fait dans
le
matchup
ok bon mais c logique en tout cas pour
Magnus
ici là le coup le meilleur semble être
le coup le plus
logique je crois qu'il part pour et qui
est la bête blanche de
Magnus B à chaque fois
ouais enfin par rapport à son niveau de
jeu peut-être je pense c'est un peu une
bête blanche mais il vient de le
battre
qu' présent comm une bête noire mais
ouais c'est une bête blanche
ouais c'est bon d'avoir des battes
blanches ouais ça fait
plaisir après il a donné une information
intéressante Magnus contre Wesley il y a
pas longtemps qui a aidé Wesley ouais
mais du coup peut-être ça l' aidé oui il
fait exprès de me laisser des coups
agressifs parce sa que je vais pas les
jouer donc du coup je dois faire ouais
pour ça qu'il faut toujours mentir en
conférence de de
presse c'est ikarou son pire matchup
alors je compte pas les parties Internet
par
contre après Magnus il domine un peu
tout le monde
hein 5
jouer
i rogant il est il est ma SC contre
Magnus et toi est-ce que tu as des bêtes
blanches et des bêtes
noires je joue plus de toute façon mais
est-ce que tu as eu des bêtes blanches
et des bêtes
noires bah gens contre qui j'ai très bon
score mais je sais pas tu vois je les ai
pas joué 50 fois comme J 50 fois non
plus quoi que dans une carre il joue
plusieurs centaines de fois en tourno
ouais maintenant il se joue tout le
temps ouais c'est même trop d'ailleurs
je veux
dire bon sement juste tour 1 ou un coup
comme ça la turb n'a pas du tout mais
pas prendre F3 c'était bête
hein c'est vrai qu'à l'époque Maxime il
avait je dire tous les joueurs en
dessous de 27 20 27 30 c'était des bêtes
blanches il avit des tel scores contre à
l'époque il est genreler je crois
que un peu même style mais é
extraordinaire comme joueur mais bon
comme ils ont 20 ans d'écart un
moment l'énergie ou quoi il avait plus à
lutter en fait sur ce terrain de
jeu B d'un gros écart leur match à bien
F4 ok B la turbinette aim bien je ça
plus logique mais4 ma FO pourquoi pas
Maxime qui rate sa
partieme pas ça être une belle partie à
montrer demain
ça on verra ou on tient peut-être une
belle partie même si c'est un peu raté
côté noir les blanc il il font un CP ce
qu'il faut faire pouruter le truc c'est
intéressant
ça le problème sur F 5 retours il y a
peut-être justusqu qu' à
4 même rchin non rchin logique he mais
je vois pas de grande découverte même si
tu fais doublechac en F3 ou en E2 bon
ben je bouge et qu' prend
B3 tu bouges quand même et qu' a un qui
ouais bon on verra mais bon c'est ça
cche on se pas trop la tête
he en fait là j'aurais limite envie
revenenir en C5 mais bon c'est un gros
aveu
de C l'ordi c'est tour F8 quand même non
mais bon non mais ça veut dire
ou Maxime qui est passé à côté du moment
important et où il jou ils sont à
Toronto au Canada
donc on mait parlé de watch party pour
cette compétition jeis pas si on la voit
ouais si vous êtes au courant ou s'il y
a des gens peut-être même dans le chat
comme c'est Toronto
c'est
5 avoir des français au Canada est-ce
que vous tes aller voir la Watch
party des
francophones après on a énorme décalage
avec le chat donc c'est pas facile
d'avoir une réponse nonon c'est dur de
faire sans trop trop
penser Maxime il est vissé le fou en
fait il sort pas juste non donc on va
gentiment jeis pas ravi de son choix
d'ouverture en fait je mattendais à ce
qu'il
[Musique]
joue d regarde il a remis la dame sur sa
case jouer la dame sera d 7 ou d D6 de
toute façon il va se faire exploser le
je peux pas le
dire dame 7 il se c'est quoi le sur dame
D6 pourquoi il l'a pas fait est-ce qu'il
a vu
qu'il don cavalier à 4 pareil en
fait s'il y avait un truc tiens j'ai une
fourchette enfin je voyais pas
[Musique]
pourquoi mais oui bon ça donne pas très
envie 4 a l'air un peu
pénible pour prendre la paire de fou
la position et puis le fou B2 il va r en
mer ouais non
c'est il se fait exploser en fait la
maxime
ouais donc je dis ouais j'ai pas trop
aimé l'ouverture je KF3 D5 C4 il peut
pas juste jouer un enfin vu son
répertoire il doit faire des qu lu enfin
ouais et du coup peut-être cavalier F3
il devait jouer cavalier F6
ais mais
c'est4 m'accepter il a pu partir pour C5
il a eu joué dans un moment ah bah oui
oui mais en fait ouais il s'est il s'est
fait ouais mais là enfin c'est un drible
en un coup quoi c'est pas une variante
donc je sais pas ou alors ça il l'avait
regardé il souvient plus trop et il
confond de trucs hein c'est enfin je
pense pas qu'il soit hors soit fait DRI
en de coup mais je sais pas il y a un
truc
qui après moi je sais pas exactement qui
est-ce qui regarde ou qu'est-ce qui
regarde pas je vois juste son apertoir
évoluer mais je suis pas dans l'équipe
donc je peux pas te dire euh euh mais
oui si tu jouaccepter et de faire ça
là-dessus il y a un truc qui est pas
cohérent
quoi Maxim qui va se battre c'est sûr
que tu es pas content d'avoir fait fou
C5 fou D6 fou C5 et tour 8 pour faire
tour D8 donc il a un truc qui va pas
après bon ben il une ce pour le cavalier
donc Magnus qui ouvre la grande
diagonale qui peut mettre un cavalier
en4 d' H5
oui ça ça a l'air bien prendre forme
pour les blancs après faudra encore
finir il va essayer de mettre des Barbel
pour défendre watch Party c'est que
vendredi et samedi hein ah oui serait
dommage de faire tous les jours pour la
finale à finalement 2 jours sera bé on
vous expliquera plus tard parce que le
le form ouais le format change tout au
long du tournoi c'est pas si simple à
comprendre donc bon là on va déjà se
concentrer sur ce qu'on voit
là
tout aussi compliqué de comprendre le
format que les
parties peut-être plus dur peut-être
plus dur ouais pour nous c'est
probablement plus
dur4 c E5 je comprends peut-être tu
revient en F5 du coup et là aprè avir
des Cali qui vont commencer à RER mais
450 contre 9 m
alors
peut-être je sais pas jeis plus jouer
d'amage 5 là il fait 4 ok let's
go c'est terrifiant le fou B2 sur la
diagonale la dame qui arrive en H5
peut-tre va avoir un décalage de tour ou
de fou il y a tout le monde et fous est
pas sorti la Toir peut pas
jouer ça pas une bonne tête
quoi c'est une très mauvaise tête même
Fab mais tout peut arriver
encore dire que tant qu'il y a pas de
gros retard matériel ou quoi
toujours trouver comment
finir mais bon tellement l'air dur AR le
damage 5 qui G4 F6 juste que tu vas rien
pouvoir reposer à ça
quoiord un avantage comme vous le voyez
mais c'est une très jolie partie là pour
le
coup en fait mag joue bien Magnus mais
Maxime pardon pas très bien quoi oui
mais ça une jolie partie mais le plan
est pas on voit pas si souvent enfin
c'est P qui avance comme ça le fou donc
non mais c'est une partie un peu modale
ouais ouais là
Magnus pourrait rejoindre Wesley à 5
victoires et s'assurer en fait la
première deè place pour être verrouillé
déjà qualifié pour les
demi-finales dem actellement F7 en
plus G6 ça va on va faire damage 4
cavalier F6 ça va ça va être mat tôt ou
tard B6 on va prendre
C55 pr F7 ouison je crois
que4 Maxime s fait
pilonner
ok donc déf quand
même juste terrifiant
ouis il se
fait pas besoin de le
dire
bien
ouvrir
pénétrer sur l' droit
évidemment
wou c'est un carton en fait hein bah tu
as pas de coup là cartonné je vois pas
même pas une idée de défense en
fait ce qui est Marant c'est que après
Caval F6 puis on prend F6 puis on prend
F6 il y a même enfin ah en plus ouais en
pas vu de base mais en fait c'est même
pas que ma en fait
j'ai rarement vu une telle écrasada hm
hm
ouais dans est parti de tel niveau là on
est que au 18e coup c'est déjà
complètement
fini est-ce qu'il peut encore r au blanc
oui oui mais genre là sur cette partie
il s'est fait euh
atomiser
on ou ça ressemble la vidéo de de la
partie de Fisher que j'ai fait que j'ai
fa hier
3 pas faire juste cavalier F6 pr
cavalier prend sur F mat sur donc dame
prend prise et là sur F
B2
pr donc faut commencer par tour
à5
B4 ça défend un tout petit peu quand
même ouais mais les coups sont pas trop
dur à
jouer et si tu fa juste F
prendz il peut-être prendre F et se
barrer vers 7 bon je sais pas si tu te
bares loin
mais tu bars pas très loin en fait ouais
ça ça
ferme F
6 en fait c'est gant tout marche tous
les trucs logiques sont bons c'est pas a
des pièges ou un truc logique ah
finalement tu as une tuas un truc en fin
de
variante c'est terrible
en fait il y a tout qui marche c'est
catacismique et ça c'est peut-être le
plus clean parce que tuas F8 x 3 K G5 en
fait il y a plus de menace il y a plus
de défense pardon qu' F un peu mais bon
même qu' F d' F7 ouis en plus en fait tu
que ro F d'un h 7 mais bon
ben ça va on peut pas croire que ça va
défendre
grandchose mais c'est une jolie
partie tu un peu l'image de la partie
d'alira contre Maxime tout à l'heure
sauf qu'alira a pas réussi à terminer là
il termine
c'était plus d' pour enfin à 3 c'était
pas encore complètement fini mais ouis
mais il était vraiment
fort 7 ouis
D7 des4v la
tour avendant
W ok donc oui il y aura une autre partie
après match retour bah d'ailleurs là on
va aller un peu voir ce qui se passe sur
les
autresou je ferai après on va voir les
autres parties
d'abord je pense qu'on pe aller voir
Fabi contre
alors la jauge al très heureuse pour
Fabi parce que c'est quand même
important ouais pour l'élimination pas
des carou mais c'est un peu une partie
du mêab celle qu'on vient de
voir alors encore faut-il finir pour
pour Fabiano alors on est c'est à
l'envers là on est à l'envers sur les
chiquers désolé le temps
de temps
d'arrivé on voit plus les joueurs parce
que la caméra est est
bouchée que les joueurs ont pas été
hyper BRIF là-dessus sur quoi sur les
caméras ouais qui c'est là ce truc vert
ah c'est Magnus ou ouis mais genre c'est
normalement tu gens sont briefés de pas
se mettre devant une
caméra ils deent même pas savoir où le
sont en fait
qui a l'air dépriméf bon il essaie de
défendre comme il peut si Fabiano se
trompe je crois qu'il a déjà fait
quelques gaff H6
apparemment déjà
faire c'est quoi
l'ouverture
fait5 il frotter à la
Rimo mais ch
finalement bah ouais après en même temps
j'ai là carou c'est pas l'ouverture le
problème quoi mais après là il peut
défendre he Fabi a l'air d'un peu se
rater peu de temps car peut peut-être
avoir un peu de bol on espère pour lui
en tout cas
fan des Chac serait déçu de pas avirarou
qualifié pour la suite de la compétition
bah c'est ce que j'ai vu sur le truc
anglais alors moi je s'il est pas
qualifié je serais plutôt content mais
on nous a dit que les fans d'échec
seraient m content de paroir Cararo à la
fin je sais alors que ben tant mieux
quoi enfin
Maxime s'est fait ouvrir en V coup et
ouais il s'est fait
ouais la partie étit
dur
exterminé nettoyé mais bon il aura sa
chance ça va partir retour on verra si
si va
revenir seran
les car sont derniers du tournoi
exactement avec la zavi qui se partage
que fait vu qu'il y a un temps d'arrêt
on est arrivé sur la
partie c'est le coup que j'avais en main
en fait mais c'est une
faute va peut-être s'en
sortir bon on verra euh c'est juste pour
mettre la partie qui a les blancs on va
pas changer de caméra on va retourner
sur Ikar quand même ça l'air intéressant
mais il est pas forcément mieux he
contre lazavic il peut prendre4 mais
prendre F2 ça va s'échanger faire une
petite nul on verra ouais ça va
probablement faire nul c'est la partie
d'ikarou là qui a l'air intéressante on
va rester dessus mais ça a l'air de de
tenir pour le streamer
américain dommage hein pour pour
Fabiano attendez je suis de nouveau à
l'envers qui a raté quand même un truc
il a raté plus 6
ouais oui non là rien de fait tuas la
paire de fou qui se pas bien
quoi ça défend fort en tout cas dans ce
tournoi bon ça n'est pas fini
complètement desespoir de de bien dans
cette partie mais mais bon il a loupé le
coche complètement mais c'est c'est un
peu sa bête noire salut à
Paul c'est un peu sa bête
noire
car non mais parce que disons la partie
au grand Suisse il est bien perdu mais
là quand tuas une telle position met
n'importe qui en face tu jou les coup
toi quoi
dame le dame D2 dame c2ou quoi
bon va faire tour G6 non juste nul
3 qu' ratéah a priori il y a quelques
coups une dizaine de coups la dame pit
s'infiltrer vers le roi
et c'est pas facile pour
ça G6 j'étais sûr ouais il mus jeu sur
contre
G2 aime pas trop mais ça doit être nul
il va peut-être même la
perdre catastrophique s
perd catastrophique pour lui après
normalement il va se qualifier quand
même Fabiano
donc
incroyable si perd ça et tuas + 6
ouais mais
ouais B8
peut-être faussi ça en fait j'ai eu ça
tout à l'heure après quand j'ai enfin je
regardais ça et j'avais en fait tout ce
truccl là enfin pas avec les ro F5
machin mais tout cette idée
là je me disais que ça devenait relou en
fait ça doit être nul quand
même pas
évident
sair que les deux fous matent seul oui
tour prion va pas suffire pour se sauver
avec les Blancs oh que
non il va qu'il essayie de pousser G4 à4
pous à droite à gauche et après les fous
défendent mal contre les pions enfin la
tour elle bien les pion
quoi mais bon il y en a qu' ils sont
deux
quoi
c'est pas mal quand arrive
G5 il doit pou
faire bloqu je sais pas 4
plutôt2 ça va
vite je comprends ce que G5 pour te
décaler le roi et après avoir des tours
D8 quand
ilendy de l'autre côté quoi
je pense qu'il a pas défendre en
fait se MRE mal aut temp en plus
attention je pensees qu'il va la perdre
fav
a des5
non
pe-être G5 maintenant
D3 3 D2 ça aller vite
parce que quand il fait D3 D2 on peut
plus3 fou C5 il veut roi ici et fou B4
ro D1
elle a ce genre de pion A4 qui l' de fou
en fait que le fou pasevenir le là ah il
ve tour D8 prion t pr D2
ouais ah c'est bien joué il peut-être C
4 quand même qui nous ont bêé
ouais ah c'est bien pensé de la part de
Fabi parce que là en fait il menace en
plus tour des8 al pas t prend TR mais si
fa tour D8 fou D6 tu es quand même
heureux
h
il s'est passé quoi les autres parties
tu peux nous dire Fab
ouais c
notamment ouais après c'est moins mais
aussi quandme on est content s' gagne
quoi alors il joue contre et il joue et
il joue toujours que donne la position
Fabien il
essaye pas que ça gagne mais on sait pas
une petite chance ouis ouais il il peut
gagner peut-être
ce qui serait bien pour lui sa c'est
plus ou moins
équilibré peut-être mieux mais on verra
qui trouve pas le gain regarde il est
dégoûté il répète les
coups mais le fou en D6 peut-être pourir
fou F4 mais fou F4 il auras simplement
ro C3 h c'est la même chose mais de
l'autre côté SAF tuuras pas fou 5as T
reprend5 et
G7 s'il fait des deux ah oui mais sauf s
fait tour D8 t reprends des de prend
reprends ah non mais tour des8 et G7 par
contre peut-être et tu as pas besoin de
sacrifier tout de suite ouais euh tu es
peut-être dans le dur là côté ikarou
parce que fou G5 G7 D2 G8 dam D2 tour D8
D8 roi
E6 g75 5
ouais reprendre des deux mais attends ro
C2 ça peut jouer le G encore
ou pas est-ce qu'ilur ah
ouais tu veux pas le gain ouais
peut-être nul mais bon je sens que
Fabiano finalement s'en sort bien mais
vu ce qu'il avait
avant Caro rcuré et donc il reste les
autres parties la zavic firouja ça fait
nul Maxime donc qui a perdu les saut
alors il reste
saut ça va faire nul donc on va pas vous
mettre les caméras là ça va se
terminer s est noir il les blanc la
prochaine tu passes derrière et tu
pousses ton pion ça c'est nul
facile est en train de la voir se
matérialiser cette
nulant
nosuxour une petite dizaine de minutes
pour à tout de suite les
[Musique]
amis
chir metal
poers now with thection from ch.com M
them ins
with and themever you like
make exus discount on
Allal with
[Musique]
thel.com
mesdames et messieurs nous sommes de
retour avec Maxime qui doit gagner pour
égaliser contre Magnus donc tu peux
mettre un petit point Magnus si tu veux
mettre score à
jour ah non c'est
l'autre
malheureusement
malheureusement Fab n des jouurs si tu
peux je le
peux et je le
peux donc Maxime avec les Blancs et ben
il va falloir essayer de battre Magnus
c'est jamais facile pour égaliser B deux
fois de
suite dans cette partie puis dans
l'armon et donc les trois autres parties
dans match sont soldé par la nul donc n
vous inquiéte vous inquiétez pas il y
aura sûrement un Armagedon après ou deux
ou trois ou quatre on espère quatre on
espère quatre évidemment puisque çaait
dire que Maxime
àarmagedon je crois que les armagon
c'est vraent le truc préféré c'est
tellement bien surtout avec cette
cadence c'est tellement intéressant
ouais
sont en place ils attendent le feu ver
des
arbitres ils ont un feu je pense ce
serait bien en fait oua le Formule 1 et
du coup alors comme vous êtes des
spécialistes mode Magnus il porte quoi
là son truc
vert bon ça m'a l'air bien mais ça doit
pas être horors de prix hein 100 € je
dirais 1200 en fait c'est qui a les SAP
les moins bien et les plus
cher mais
cher mais sais je crois que c'est dur de
de faire marcer une pièce je crois que
c'est vraiment plus dur des trucs chers
je crois que c'est dur àfin à porter
ouais je crois qu'il faut faire vendre
des trucs super bien mais je crois que
c'est le plus dur en
fait pour que le truc soit cher il faut
qu'il soit un peu tu vois original
généralement c'est un peu
c'est chelou c'est un peu du Désigual
mais cher quoi ouais mais du coup ça
peut être très beau si c'est bien amené
tu
voisir le tempérament et tout pour le
porter aussi peut le porter aussi
ouespagnol
italien espagnol 46 D3 peut-être et non
il a roqué
plutôt Jama facile de battre Magnus dans
ses espagnols NP sétait cassé les dents
dessus
antimarchal don on Marchall et laqu il
va choisir Magnus B8 B4 B4 ok il sait
toutes les jouer ça c'est de la f
fashion qu' ça do coûter 30 balles comme
quoi on peut faire mie avec 30 balles
qu'avec 1800 pas qu'une question
d'argent
Fab Magnus qui a peut-être du goût oui
pour
étonnamment alors que Théodor qui est
spécialiste de tu spames les trucs très
chers ça ressemble à une œuvre d'art
moderne faut un truc cher et des trucs
chip
ala est sappé comme un boss de cartel
enfin ouais mais le problème c'est qu'il
a pas c'est un peu vrai je trouve mais
il a tellement pas l'attitude qui va
avec il faut les dents en or et
tout mais oui ça ressemble un peu à ça
ouais
son et ouais donc pour revenenir à la
position donc c'est légèrement
symétrique on a provoquer l'avancé du
pionb et donc on espère avec les Blancs
pouvoir les embêter via C C4 et
peut-être aussi un moment faire A5
nous-même euh pour réactiver le fou vers
A4 et qui est peut-être le pion à 6 sont
un peu arriéré et faible un jour si on
met le F C4 ou des petits détails comme
ça c'est pas grand-chose
mais mais B Magus joue tellement bien
cette position oui oui oui c'est bah
c'est sûrement le
meilleurin dans dans ses positions
peut-être un A5 ici
directement pourquoi
pas peut-être un dame
2 dame de
jouer permet peut-être de faire k C4
après sans perdre voilà ouais en D 2 je
pense c'est le coup le plus logique he
joué par par par
Maxime et Magnus B qui va peut-être soit
faire dame 7 à son tour
se paraît pas un petit tour8 pour faire
fou pr F7 dame C4 et dame prend C5 tu en
aimerais
bien
Maxime qui peut
égaliser pe-être maintenant à
5 j' peur de a5re qu' ve A5 F B5
ouaisali C4 pour essayer
de
B de G4 bah écoute tu peux le faire
après bon les blancs vont t défendre
avec T puis chasser le cavalier donc
après à toi de voir si tu penses que ça
t utile ou quoi mais en soit c'est tou
un coup tu peux regarder parce que
peut-être tu peux l'enchaîner avec avec
tu pouvais faire F5 ou quoi là bon cloué
tu peux pas trop mais voir
dit qu'il est plutôt natation que ça
Magnus c'est vra qu'il est il est assez
stock il fait beaucoup de sport en fait
ouais depuis toujours il aime bien le
foot le basket le tout tout
quoi les
échecs
je crois qu'il est pas très bon aux
autres sports moins bon qu'au
échecs mais il doit se débrouiller pour
un amateur je veux
dire non mais le coup ça joue c'est pas
malre que maxima
jouer toutes les pièces sur les
chiquers c'est quand même quelque chose
et il y a une petite initiative he quoi
qu'il en soit et oui c B3 qui su dans le
chat aussi ça peut être une idée pour
les blancs ça permettra de développer le
fou C1 en G5 donc donc pourquoi
pas faut qu'il égalise la maxime mais
bon avant ça évidemment c'est Magnus de
jouer
donc dis pasa FO cisme pas terrible
terrible pour des pourelun qui joue pas
il joue
biens tu le mettas avec Jeurs de foot il
serait pas ouf
mais mais pour faire des matchs amicau
machin comme ça avec des joueurs d'échec
il est pas mal ou quand tu vois comment
joue
Maxime pas non plus très
difficile déjà il a un bon physiquement
il tient le coup quoi il peut
cavaler je sais pas techniquement oui
c'est pas
Zidan sur F3 tu veux
quoi tu que je F3 pour B3
B2 question je sais pas exactement
mais tu fa juste marquage des B34 pour
pas avir le cavalier
[Musique]
d alors
tuuxid a les no tu P
mais fais
ça
ça va très he en
fait Maxime qui réfléchit en tout cas
mais moi le foot bon je jouis la régré
quand j'étais petit comme tout le monde
tu vois enfin donc bon voilà enfin non
je suis nul quoi j'étais enfin oui donc
ça veut dire bien dire que je suis nul
j'étais mais j'étais pas mal en gardien
pour de vrai en fait
euh mais bon j'ai jamais joué dans des
vraies cages mais j'avais des réflexes
intéressants Ste de petit chat quoi dans
ses cages au poste le plus relou quoi
mais j'aimais bien ça m'allait bien mais
voilà après dans le jeu sinon non je
rien de SP quoi tu me mets un peu milieu
enfin un truc
voilà Mau défensif ça m'aurait ça
m'aurait ça m'aurait allé mais bon là
j'ai pas j'ai pas le cardio quoi
j'aurais j'aurais sué après après 3
minutes de jeu quoi B3 direct il a même
pas fait fou
D3 al pas du tout à cause de à cause de
à cause de cavalier
H5 bon c H5 c'est un coup logique quand
même en fait l'avantage si tu tir profil
fait que le cavalier doiv bouger pour
défendre la case
F4 ce momentl ouais il y a du sens euh
ouis après je sais pas pourquoi il
rechoté fout D3 qui en soit moi j'aimis
bien F5 B3
d'ailleurs
ouais pour parler de sport en comme dit
la Gana puis en fait il faut que tu aies
une une condition physique correcte pour
pour pour tenir rester concentré
longtemps et cetera mais tu les vois
tous tuends pas ce soit des grands
sportifs non plus mais ils font gen un
mec comme carwana il doit aller faire
son footing ou je sais pas trop quelle
est son hygiène mais il a il a peut une
bonne hygiène nepo qui qui avait le bide
bon il a dû un peu se bouger faire des
trucs pour pour tenir et cetera quoi
qu'il a pas réussi d'ailleurs non mais
bon
c'estut réussi au candidat en
général mais même Ding tu vois je le
vois pas comme grand sportif
quoi mais donc oui de base c'est bien si
quand même tu as une bonne condition que
tu tiens tu peux rester concentré tu as
pas des trous d'air jry carou qui fait
pas très sportif lui il a ce côtél où il
peut tu peux streamer longtemps et
cliquer et et voilà
ouais carou il a une bonne force de
concentration HM sans faire de
sport enfin peut-être qu'il fait deux
trois trucs he j'en sais rien
mais mais donc oui je sais j'ai vu dans
le chat avant c'est les échecs c'est un
sport en fait oui c'est considé comme
sport
euhès bon oui on peut se poser la
question hein ça reste juste un truc
cérébral mais mais c'est dans la liste
des des
sports SP intellectuel maintenant en
France ah on a mis la distinction bah
c'est plus normal en fait je suis
d'accord en fait c'est le côté
intellectuel qui en fait un sport du
coup parce que c'est des confrontations
pas le côté mais c'est pas un sport à
proprement parler en fait bah c'est non
pas de d'habilité physique
ou ou de de précision ou
quoi donc moi personnellement j'ai mal à
le placer comme sport après je comprends
la dimension sportive dans le face- à
faceace dans les tournois dans les
choses comme ça dans la pression enfin
par certains aspects oui mais l'activité
en
elle-même c'est pas un truc très sportif
quoi
en tout cas Magnus qui a pas trouvé le C
H5 et qui a échangé le fou
C4 donc il a la paire de fou
mais Max s'est plutôt bien installé qui
va PIR un peu
viser ce pion ce pion5 comme il le fait
il propose l'échange de d'un fou donc il
y aura plus de paire de fou en
face
c'est vrai que les Noirs ils ont un
petit dilemme par tu as envie de faire a
5 mais après tu as tour8 partir do dé
non la maxime il domine et donc il y a
ce côté-là pas si
simple pe la gagner C
ouais golf bah ouais mais golf c'est du
sport parce que tu marches beaucoup déjà
dans la journée et puis tu dois viser
quoi
enfè aussi en fait physique tu as de la
force à mais tu marches aussi beaucoup
tu fais des kilomètres
de voilà après ok l'quitation ça on peut
se questionner rester debout sur le
cheval ou quoi pas tomber mais c'est
dur une agilité physique avir une mais
complètement les éche tu as même pas
besoin DEAS
beso pour les
coupqu to le cheval habité physique
c'est hyper
chevalation dur pour le cheval
aussi que chev comme un sportif je pense
C3 faute d'après l'ordi parce que ça
fait virer le pion B3
après mais genre oui les fléchettes
c'est un sport parce que tuas l'agilité
ouais faut viser quoi ti à l'arc tout ça
voilà
ouis bon c'est évident c'est pas la
peine de partirus j'ai l'habitude d'
chat twitch toujours quelques personnes
de très mauvaise fois qui vont essayer
de te dire l'inverse mais
c'est pas très intéressant de parler
avec ces
gens-là t à
C1
si on prend les trois t prend ouais tu
mets quand même la pression encore bah
il essay puis a une meilleure structure
et cetera après C3 ouais c'est un coup
responsable qui change quand même un peu
la donne dans la position mais pourquoi
pas
maxime est de au mur de toute façon il
est obligé de de gagner pour égaliser
voilà qui à prendre des risque et même
perdre c'est pas grave
he
oh que
non je sais pas comment je départage en
cas d'égalité ça on nous l'a pas dit
est-ce que il y a l'admin chesscom là
dans le chat comment ça quel match de
départage euh genre si tu arrives à deux
victoires chacun qui est 5e qui est 6e
qui est 7e de un Go à verrage c'est que
c'est
peut-être pas idot pas perdre quoi
de pas de prendre des 2-0 d'ù peut-être
pourquoi Abdou hier a essayé de gagner
le ce que SAU fait pas lui mais ouais
c'est peut-être pour ça ouais
sur C prend B il veut jusqu
ou alors en fait après tu fais cavalier
a 5 et C c6ou dame prend et ouais mais
fait c'est prend B tour prend il prend
le 5 est-ce qu'on a du tour prend B3 qui
va arri un
moment donc enfin je pour ça fr ça va
pas quoi aussi je pense
du coup tu attaques deux fois on peut
pas le
défendre tu arriver non
ouais
malheureusement
bien joué
hein et si on commence par cavalier a 5
il fait fout D7 c'est ça
ouais pour faire la même c'est Prom et
partir [__] c'est hyper bien
joué tellement dur mais do connaître
tous ces thèmes en fait
mais c'est très dur à trouver non c'est
dur mais en fait quand tu connais tu
connais bah ser Magnus hein la caméra
tranquille ah là c'est fort ce qu'il a
fait donc CB
cavalier qui s'en
va ah c a 5 on envie de faire quand BL a
cavalier a 5 F D7 qui C6 et rentrer
là-dedans quand même
ouais Bou tour prend tour B4 tour A6 il
va doubler les
tours c'est pas évident ça tu bien
bloqué qui c 5 qui arrive ou mais bon ok
si tuavais garder un pion de plus
peut-être c'est la partie en tout
cas je suis très impressionné par
l'enchaînement de Magnus quand même
ouais une position pas évidente il
arrive à trou les coups précis
pour quasiment égaliser pour égaliser
plus ou moins
ou c'est très fort là ce qu'il vient de
faire
W
ok il joue dame D3 il va viser un petit
peu ce pion à
6 que T
B6 pas mal de trucs en plus à les tours
des6 qui peuvent
arriver je crois qu'il va la tenir à
Magnus juste par curiosité je fais juste
un micro tour suraro
ok quel est
blanc bon sement çaarmon tout ça et bon
vas-y on faire un micro tour de
tout regardeous notre côté ça a l'air
d'être égal et la zavic firou ça a l'air
d'être égal aussi
bon on va pas perdre trop de temps tour
B6
jouer
ouais Maxim joue qui demande on a
dit je sais
pasana Carana ouais ouais je
pense
est-ce que s'il perd ce
match là si fou perd contre la Davic
c'est c'est fini tout pour lui plus ou
moins Mo je va la case D5 je pense que
tu arrives en F4 avant mais
tu DESC quand
même C6 alors Mo je question C6 ça
pourquoi
pas tu as encore tes chances quand M
avec les
Blancs peut-être même
pr égalité confrontation directe
ok donc Maxim
aarou
et si plusieurs joueurs sont en égalité
ça être le
cas confrontation direct S se font une
tournante l'un B
l'autre il jou on nous dit
ok
égalité
[Musique]
ok
ouais est-ce que vous pensez qu'une
compétition comme celle-ci pourrait
devancer champion du monde en terme de
prestige bah non pas du tout là pour le
moment c'est même pas proche en fait non
mais du monde rien l'galera jamais en
fait
un autre champion du monde alors faudra
une autre fédération que la FIDE ou quoi
qu'un truc se montre en parallèle et
voilà mais c'est le titre suprême
quoi alors après qu' a plus d'argent
ailleurs que le championnat du monde ça
sera çaarrivera surûrement d'ailleurs
pas c'est sûr non pour l'instant c'est
pas le cas mais ça ça pourrait arriver
si jamais ils veulent envie de la cayas
à fond
mais le prestige
oui on connait tous les champions du
monde de l'histoire les matchs qui ont
marqué l'histoire du jeu et cetera
c'est là la la Jae c'est juste qu'il y a
eu un bug hein ne vous inquiétez
pas enin ou inquiétez-vous plutôt parce
que c'est complètement
égal
ça pas bien compris comment marché la
Calif bon tu as suivi en fait le tournoi
il y a h joueurs qui sont là et ils font
un tournoi comme tuen vois tout le temps
sauf que de se jouer une seule partie un
tout rond comme il font d'abitude il se
font des matchs en match à l'etour blanc
noir il y a un gars qui gagne un gars
qui perd les matchs quoi tu marqu tu
gagnes tu marques un point tu perds tu
marques zé bon
voilà et s'il y a un partout dans les
matchs il faut une trè partie pour se
départager le fameux Armageddon mais
quoi qu'il en soit tu marques un point
ou
zéro à chaque match à la fin il font
l'addition de tout et tuas un classement
1er 2è 3e machin n prier 2è se qualifie
d'office pour les demi-finale 7e 8e les
deux derniers éliminé et les autres il
doivent encore aller en demifinale et et
voilà plus tu finis au classé plus tu as
de chance quand même d'y aller tu tu as
moins d'efforts à faire on va dire mais
c'est ça le principe donc le de base tu
vises d'être dans les deux premiers
c'est tu arrives pas bah il faut éviter
les deux dernières places quoi après là
je suis un peu inquiet Fab c'est à
partir des demi-finales parce que ça va
jouer euh enfin ça va jouer en deux
jours ils seront au meilleurs des quatre
parties ouais et je suis inquiet qu'en
partie 15 + 2 si les parties
s'enchaînent des journées très courtes
peut-être ça jouera que 2h30 ou
3h alors tu tu penses qu'on sera
peut-être pas bien sûr et après de
cumuler deux journées comme ça
finalement ça nous fera quand même
peut-être bien 5 6h la
demi-finale j'espère qu'il y aura quand
même un peu des belles pauses
à Maxime si vous nous voyez un peu pr
risque ça lui échappe quand
même il P pas prendre av une découverte
oui
Défensea
Magnus
là a priori C5 a l'air bon simplement
parce que il a deux pièces attaqué le FO
4 et le C aussi c'est en un coup il fait
une pierre de coup
quoi là ça va être perdant bah c'est un
pion de moins
malheureusement c'est un pion de moins
euh pas TR de compensation ça va mal
tourner cette partie quoi mais bon çaz
fort en fait dur à mettre en danger dur
à déstabiliser
serein
William PRS Maxime bon benah écoute il
arrive à battre àireza donc il a encore
ses chances pour la calife mais c'est
pas fait c'est pas un grand tour de sa
part quoi qu'il en soit
quoi
on peut faire un tout petit tour une
nouvelle fois juste on regarde alorsar
qui
semble il gagner un mais bon il va la
gagner
contre 30 contre gagner qui va
gagner qui est pas forcément au
mieuxar restera laav en plus en dernier
donc il va se qualifier quand Mme quoi
qu'il en
soitche PEV être rassuré
rassuré Maxime qui tente
tout donc a quand même réussir à finir à
à trois trois victoires avec
Caro
quiit finir 5 ou 6 mais qui sait
peut-être avec le départage pe même r
une 4e place
ça ça serait chanceux la
prestation donc f Il la forchette
en7 et vous voyez C J qui va de mal en
P ça joue sur le mat en en fin de
variante beaucoup de dans lesqu il a ce
truc ave mat là
l'ordinateur c'est une GAE mais parce
que c'est pas pour perdre quoi pour pas
gagner et encore on
verra raté en fait
4 6 il a juste
raté alors
peut-être
tour C8 ou
ouais ça passe quand
même prend le 4 tuas pas le temps de
faire t
C7 la première rangée qui est
vraiment qui aura coûté cher à
Maxime é es content d'avoir un petit H3
jouer un
moment après aux échecs av un temps de
plus
ouais beaucoup de parties se perdent
autant près quand
même pour vite pour
liquider ouis bon toute façon il va pas
gagner ça Maxime non peut-être perdre
mais pas gagner aprs 35 secondes en face
mais t C8 ça l'air vraiment non je
sais il s'endort sa pas a 3 secondes là
quand même Fab c'est pas
comme mais 3 c'est beaucoup tuavais
oublié non ch qu' a du rajou je sais
plus à quel
point ouais pas terrible on peut
peut-être aller voirarou vite fait tu
que c'est quand même intéressant il y a
il y a une calife en
jeu
sal
c'estarou je pense qu'il la gagne ou
pas
B plutôt
non ESS tenir au courant sur les parties
des Français ok je les
Français savoir ce qui se
passe
surtout resa ENF faut regarder quand
même ça a l'air bien complexe bon lesz
resa euh je dirais que ça va aller
àarmagedon
allez ben ça joue hein il peut perdre il
peut gagner mais a priori vu la tte de
la position nul plus probable
voilà Maxime ça do pas s'améliorer
particulièrement je dire même s'il fait
nul c'est c'est l'élimination donc bon
il se bat mais voilà et euh il soit déjà
fait nul sen volant on vers un nouvel
armé
Gayon ça après ce on l'a dit avec 5
victoires déjà il est assuré hein ouais
il a bien bien joué pr caméra
chezaro exactement ouais peut-être
quelqu'un qui est
devant exactement de noir vêtu bien ce
que je
pensais calcu
ikcaro il ont décidé de tous se mettre
devant la
caméra
alors que Fab essaie de trouver des des
renseignements qu' réser va réussir à
battre la zavic
ou pas on peut le laisser en
fond ils ont 30 secondes chacun c'est
chaud qui essaie d'avancer en tout cas
pour l'instant il y a pas d'échec enfin
il y a d'ame des a 6 quand même he mais
tuas par
il y a pas il y a pas de série d'échec
on va
dire G4 pourquoi peut-être pour faire r
G3 et
non dam j'aurais bien fait
ok
D
OK ou
C2 très bien s
veut échec mais c'est pas sur la 8e pour
l'instant et la D D5 pour bombarder
d'échec
prendrea temp mais
pourstant
B8
C qu je fais d
[Musique]
c78
d
C8 est bien D5 fa le TA
central
j'ai position
potentiellement nul signé chez
d'aurs nul signé chez alirza Maxim a
fait
nul voilà donc a perdu le match on
savait arm Magon et il a cette partie
attendre son
terme encore un petit
peu est devant la cam son beau
pull est-ce qu'on peut dire qu' qu' a
350 balles devant la
cam on
peut encore c'est que le pull c'est pas
qu'il a
de c'est quand même beau de réussir à
perd la cam alors que tu as pas de
spectateur ça me but
F8 do aller G8
n'importe je sais pas s'il y a un piège
à éviter là pour l'instant je vois pas
tellement non il peut y avoir unné
échec6 truc donc pour l'instant tu
restes sur F7 justement pas qu' F6 échec
la surtout de pas se mettre trop trop
mal au temps mais ça va il tient son ses
30 secondes quo que tu TS essayer
d'avoir au moins 20 secondes quoi bon F
j'imagine mais je pense tu es content de
de plus être sous la pression du temps
enfin d'avoir plus de temps que
l'autre
ça vrai dire tu es très content de te
faire bombarder d'échecs
50 coup tu l'as pas trop
là
peut-être d4en
fous moi je pense vraiment qu' doir une
règle dans les parties retransmises que
sil a trois fois la même position
l'arbitre peut intervenir en fait c'est
comme si on notait mais sauf que le
joueur normalement doit réclamer de
lui-même oui mais gen en fait c'est
débile genre là évidemment pas le temps
de il réclame ouais mais gen en fait tu
peux pas
savoir ça va encore durer des plombes
mais je pense qu'il y a pas non il y a
pas parce que nous on le verrait avec
l'ordi et tout à l'heure là quand il a
refit un dam des 6 écheac par contre moi
je pensais que oui il que de à 7 il y a
pas encore PLRE des plombs mais c'est
bien ça faire durer le truc un peu plus
longtemps moi je pense que l'arbitre
doit être obligé de dire tu peux
demander
nul
c'est plus dans l'esprit de la règle en
fait bah la règle en fait c'est si tu
demandes pas toi-même oui je sais mais
en fait enfin ça est dév la règle oui
débile ENF tu changer là et quand il y a
tro fois une position TR fois une
position parce que même la manière dont
tu la demander en lente elle est débile
ouais c'est pas tu joues ton coup
tuarrêtes ça fait TR fois tu dois noter
alors tu es pas censé noter t coup avant
de
jouerant tu dois noter avant arrêter la
pendule aller chercher un arbitre
reconstituer bon
ok le protocole
quoi complètement débile surtout pour
les parties
retransmises du coup oui c'estéquivalent
de ce qui est beau c'est qu'en plus ils
ont même pas de système qui vaut
automatiquement si TR fois la même do
reconstier c'est est 2023
quoiô mais fais
voir perso est-ce que c'était cel
non
celui pour moi il y non pas F4 d
F5 D C une fois celui-à deux
fois ah [__] céit pas la D sur cas F33
okç le truc te monre lesbit quand même à
la main je crois ils ont pas le truc
automatique du coup une pénalité a
ouais si l'aré tu rajoutes du temps des
carou alors bon il a le SAM là
d'habitude c'est 2 minutes mais là je
sais
pas vra dire la règle est vraiment
bizarre il lu amène un écran un ordi
portable pour
constituer mais comment ça se fait que
tuas un truc informatique qui te le
disent une V quoi mais c'est quand même
pas très dur à
coder non j'arrive pas à comprendre en
fait ça me dépasse bah c'est comme ça
non mais genre les échecs ça me dépasse
enfin il y a des trucs
c'est là les ils sont pour rien mais en
2024 pas encore un truc sur la même
position qu'on s'est retransmis pour le
savoir automatiquement bah nous on le
Saur
mais comment estce qu'il a pas un truc
officiel qu'il le fasse je sais pas ça
me paraîre ça doit prendre 5 minutes à
CER comment ça a jamais été fait en fait
on a des des codeurs vous pourriez le
faire
et ça reprend et ils ont rajouté 2
minutes à
car et Fabi qui pourra pas
réclamer
c'est B queuss r
réclame de manière
erronée
ça repris mais bon du coup qui réfléchit
qui voit s trouve une idée un plan un
piège un truc mais objectivement la N
juste donc toutçon il va pas trouver
grandchose sa seule chanceouer
vite prier pour pour une erreur
adversestant pour ça trop dur
faire
le temps qu'il a perdu ça a pas coûter
grand-chose au final non parce que il y
en a déjà une minute 20 qui est passé
ben bah rien faire mais je crois que tu
peux juste rien faire dans la position
là je CIS peut-être non attends il y a
pas d'ame ahame
je riens
dame87 pas bête H5 du coup il reparti
chez lui bien sur F6 il veut ro G6 je
pense
G3 d D4 du coup H5 on CRA plus tu V
juste
refire7
5 plus secondes quand
même reparti
G8 pas jouer d
finalement si finalement
si bon est aussi mal au temp que
Fabi dizaine de secondes pour les deux
joueurs je CIS il va revenir
en3ame 4 qui faisit PERP derre par qu'il
avait damin
maintenant
bon ça pas mal là quand
même
ça peut faire juste
nul 3 doit venir défendre le
G5 encore F4 d
G23 4 H5 D
machin fait TR fois non non peut-être
pas
ça va il a réussi à
remonter n
çaarm pe pa quandme avant pour reprendre
le souffle et puis bien faire les
enchres exactement et on se retrouve
donc dans une dizaine de minutes pour
les arm aura beaucoup il y que Maxim qui
tout suite
suite don't see it how about now manage
your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things a new opening for your wall is
here capture new major pieces on unique
metal posters from displate now with the
official collection from Chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolfe magnet kit
and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
chess at
[Musique]
displate.com
alors on va
suivre lazavic contre firouja
ok je te propose après mais ça me paraît
intéressant ben très
bien un match qu'on pas du tout suivi
puis on a quand même envie de voir si
ala va réussir à à
s'imposer garder ses chances pour la
Calif parce qu'en cas de défaite c'est
vrai
que on sera un peu inquiet sera dur
ouais je sais pas quel encher il a
mise on ver pendu l'arrivée mais je suis
pas au courant de donc
du du temps pour all on a vu
d'autres je crois que
938 Wes tellement heureux de faire ces
petit nul
[Musique]
W on va voir là
c'est fait c'est le duel derniers en
fait oui je pense que le perdon de ce
match finira dans les deux dernières
places accompagné bon ben on sait pas
par qui encore peut-être par Maxime
peutêtre par Maxime peut-être par un
autre d'ici en ou
pararoouvert tarrache est-ce que c'est
une pas à l'envers
si coup ça
M
que la Pan tu es pas déjà juste quoi
donc en
fait fait le temps sert à
rien
C5 tu récèes ton truc pu ça va
non
expert
m' dit que BUP à l'honneur sur la page
de la féd bah écoute j'ai ouais j'ai
longuement discuté après avec avec Elois
du coup le président et je crois qu'il a
bien
kiffé en fait on a réussi à faire un
truc qui a fait kiffer tout le monde à
l'unanimité ouais c'est bien ça fait
plaisir pu j'avais vu aussi un tweet de
Jean-Baptiste Mulon viceprésident de la
FD qui av qui suiv en direct sur
Internet euh j'ai aussi un dirigent de
ligue venir voir le le tournoi non cé
assz incroyable donc cool cool cool cool
que que les gens euh même haut placé
euh bon s intéresse il trouve ça bien
quoi
ouais je crois que l'objectif Ctait
vraiment de faire passer un bon moment
aux gens avant tout et et ça a
fonctionné quoi ça aurait pu ne pas
fonctionner après mais je crois que
c'est
ressenti donc car se qualifie s'il gagne
contre Fabi c'est pas suffisant mais euh
en fait je crois que son match de demain
est plus important contre lazavic
bizarrement fait j'ai l'impression que
même si perd et qui bavic il aura pas
mal de chance mais bon tu es pas sûr
alors que là si tu gagnes et que tu
gagnes oui
c'est ça mais en fait si tu gagnes et tu
perds je crois que tu es sûr d'être
éliminé parce que laav te revient à de
victoires en fait je crois que c'est
juste s'il gagne aujourd'hui il s'assure
que victoire contreav le bas le qualifie
pardon et s'il perd victoire contre le
qualifie probablement que défaite demain
l'élimine dans les deux
casavi qui ferme des bouches dans ce
tournoi il s'est présenté même sil est
dernier
non il est complètement claqué au
sol je sa il sera jamais top mondial il
a 17 ans il est il est nul quoi enin
nul relativement au joueurs du même
âge par par rapport à pragananda ou ou à
les réseau au même âge
tu veux prendre les coucaches les AR
Jaun tout ça ou même des jou un peu de
second plan
ouais contrairement à darda il na jamais
gagné la
BUP mais en vrai ouais il a même moins
d' que darda
peut-être en tout cas darda plus
impressionné Morid aussi enfin je sais
pas impressionne personne du toutf ferme
aucune bouche il était nul au grand
Suisse il a gagné un match contre Maxime
qui a fait nimp
mais de gagner un match sur 6 quoi non
mais c'est dur moi je voyais tous les
perdes donc quelque part il a fermé ma B
bouge mais mais mais bon on voit qu'il
est en dessous
quoi bon là du coup il essaye de
conserver son pion de
plus mais en gros moi je connaissais pas
du tout hein ce
mec pas qui c'est quoi en fait je voyais
à chaque fois dans ces tournois là ah
qualifieré qualifié bon bravo mais je
l'ai jamais vu rien faire en réel donc
je sais pas moi je le connais pas donc
je peux pas trop
dire CRAM av en ligne de mire mais ENF
je il Ava toujours autant en ligne de
mire après ce tournant enfin grere c'est
ça va rien changer en fait de toute
façon les trucs sur Internet c'est juste
que c'est d'une autre époque ça peut
plus exister
donc mais je sais pas trop comment dire
ENF je vais me répéter une enè fois mais
la question c'est pas est-ce que ça
triche sur Internet ou pas ou est-ce que
un tel triche en autre triche qui prend
le le problème à l'envers déjà et
l'autre problème c'est que de toute
façon comme c'est possible de tricher de
manière assez élémentaire on s'en fiche
si tu qui le fait ou qui le fait pas
c'est trop simple et trop t temp vu les
les som jeu de toute façon donc en soit
la question c'est pas est-ce que tu
est-ce que un tel a triché ou un tel a
pas triché le truc c'est que n'importe
qui peut tricher c'est facile et donc en
fait ça n'a aucune valeur que tu
performes bien ou tu performes mal donc
en fait tes tournois sur Internet les
résultats devraient enfin je v même pas
te les compter en fait ça m'intéresse
juste pas mais gen c'est
normal enfin moi je suis pas ardent
défenseur sur internet donc non ce que
c'est qu'il faut prendre le problème
dans ce sens là faut pas accuser les
gens c'est juste que en fait t résultats
n'existent pas et on juste on compr pas
pourquoi il y a autant d'argent pour un
truc qui est pas sécurisé c'est plus ça
le truc mais c'est même pas contre les
sites qui les organisent ou quoi parce
que eux c'est impossible en fait de
faire autrement il y a pas de c'est un
problème sans solution donc mais ce que
fait CRAM ça sert rien non plus enfin
non mais tu peux écrire des interesting
1000 fois par jour mais enfin de toute
façon tu proposes pas de solution non
ouais tu as beau dire un TR tel triche
sûrement ah bah enfin et alors en
fait quand même tu réussiras à le
prouver tu vas changer quoi B c'est un
problème sans solution
quoi c'est pas
grave ou quoi mais gen crramni il est
bien gentil avec tous ces trucs mais où
est enfin qu'est-ce qu'il propose en
fait rien de jouer sans faire les
rocks qu Mme dis rigolant un peu je sais
pas ce qu'il propose mais non mais il
propose vraiment rien non mais c'est
proposer de toute façon enfin soit
tuarrêes les T sur Internet et tu fais
des hybrides et des tourns Réal mais
même les tournant réel on a vu qu'il y a
des problèmes moi je propose fouille
tout le temps de de tout partout délai
énorme euh tu as un téléphone sur toi
que tu as oublié BIM je te suspends je
rien à [__] jeis même pas savoir ce
que tu en as fait ou pas je te donne pas
le bénéfice du doute et cetera quoi mais
j' partir d' un certain niveau pour ça
par exemple gen mais les mecs à 12 à
partir de 2400 ou suivant les tournois
ou quoi bon quand tu non mais quand tu
fais des des beaux tournoi par standing
internationaux ou les championnats
nationaux bon
il a la technique du PL le fion ça a été
mis en place Al il y a un youtubeur qui
l'a fait là il y a pas longtemps qui a
battu un grand maître en utilisant un
plug premier degré ok je sais pas bon je
s mis un plug dans le fion pour voir bon
pour faire le boss quoi et il a gagné
enfin très facilement quoi l'autre dis
don les coups en morce Nonant c'est une
technique possible et c'est pour le coup
très difficile de lutter contre parce
que pour avoir le droit même dans un
tournoi physique de faire une fouille
anale de faire une fouille anale c'est
vraiment pas facile
pas je c'est un peu embêtant il pas tous
les joueurs au début de la partie non
mais non mais non ben oui benah oui
c'est pas
facile je suis pas sûr que j'accepterai
quoi après c'est pour la sécurité du
tourno bon oui bon je joue pas le
tournoi pu je m'en fous oui voilà
mais
tout mouton qui a récupér mais pas
complètement tout
quoi qui a le plus beau P entre les
deux bon je préfère cel
d'
on dit des mesures minimal les par
exemple jouer sans écouteur ça sert à
rienf moi ça le truc le plus débile non
ça devraitêre normal qu' pas d'écouteur
mais en so s veulent vraiment tricher
vont y arriver parce qu'ils vont pas te
dire qu'ils ont des écouteurs que tu
verras pas la
cam en l'occurrence et
bon pas d'écouteur ok mais ça rés pas
grandchose rien en fait non mais enfin
il y a une mesure moi j'ai déjà proposé
qui
marche CIT quoi de jouer en hybride ah
oui mais ça je sur ordinateur si tu veux
mais depuis un lieu enfin ce que
j'organise en fait mais c'est la seule
solution en fait ça sert à rien de
j'arrive pas à comprendre l'intérêt des
demi-mesures en fait
oui non mais les demi-mesur c'est ça j'
rien marcher pour rien ou euh non mais
l'autre truc qui est discutable même
philosophiquement parlant mais mais euh
c'est de
de mettre un système informatique en
place et quand tu as une un
doute trop peu de doute que genre il y a
999 chances sur 1000 que ça triche ou
quoi bah tu es suspendu ouais ça triche
alors ok il y aura une personne sur 1000
qui peut-être ouais mais c'est pas une
solution parce que les top niveau tu
sauras jamais en fait mais si le truc se
clignote bah tant pis et tu signes un
agrément avant le tournoi que tu
acceptes que la techie soit utilisé si
tu tris juste un coup par tournoi il le
verra pas
impossible ça marche pas non plus en
fait non mais tu peux le mettre enfin
mais comme j'ai dis philosophiquement
est-ce que on accepte que peut-être un
sur 1000 qui non déjà ça marche pas et
en plus ouais non mais faut enfin faut
juste arrêter jouer depuis la maison je
sais pas quoi dire en fait non mais moi
je suis contre depuis toujours en fait
c'est comme si au cyclisme tu disais on
ve Inter le dopage mais tuas plein genre
c'est comme si vélo tu disais faut plus
qu'il y a de dopage mais le seul truc
que tu as pas le droit de prendre comme
mesure c'est de faire des contrôles
antiopag je veux dire je comprends très
bien le problème j'ai jamais trouvé ça
bien j'ai jamais joué de sur Internet
perso ça me fait chier en fait ce truc
et je compris pas qu'il y a tout le
temps plus de fric encore plus et encore
plus alors queon connaitt le fléo mais
bon ben c'est comme ça mais le problème
c'est que ça touche aussi les CHS en
réel quoi donc ouais mais je pense qu'il
faut plus se concentrer sur ce problème
là régler ce problème là et puis truc
Internet de
façon ça pour dire pour les gens qui
parlent laavic la zavic ENF on s'en fout
de laavic en fait c'est pas la zavic le
problème tu sauras jamais si ce qu'il
fait chez lui mais tu peux pas l'accuser
de là qu'il fasse quelque chose quelqu
chose de mal donc tant mieux pour lui
qui joue bien ici he enfin bravo à lui
mais mais je pense toujours pas qu'il
sera champion du monde dans 2 ans quoi
c'est ce que je veux dire non je pense
pas non plus sa performance me donne pas
l'impression qu'il a le niveau d'un
pragananda au même âge ou
quoi al on dit va perdre sûrement jeais
quand même aller voir si c'est pas une
faut
chat quel avantage hybride par rapport à
un tour OTB classique bah il y en a deux
en fait déjà c'est que tu peux voir les
parties générement il y a beaucoup de
problèmes de
retransmission encore que là sur ce
tournoi c'est pas si mal c'est pas fini
he enfin car est mieux mais c'est pas en
rapide et en blit mais aussi c'est que
ça permet de ah non d'avoir moins de
voyage et non pour le coup pour le Blitz
ça bah il y en a pas dans ce tournoi
donc ça va par du monde de Blitz que tu
suis chaque année ah ouais c'est imp pe
c'est dur à suivre ou tu peux pas avir
les parties en
fait parce que des fois tu te prends des
ses de coup des fois ça bug une pice qui
est renversée c'est pas là des fois il y
a une petite pls mais ils arrivent à
vite remettre en place quand même euh n
faudra une autre technologie que le DGT
ou trouver autre chose si jamais ils
veulent perdurer là dessus et euh et
voilà je sais pas non mais l'autre
avantage hybride c'est que pour les les
coups genre que c'est très cher
d'organiser un T d'échec ah bon après en
terme de mais même en fait pour
enchaîner c'est pas mal parce que tu as
pas besoin d'arbitre de refaire les
appareillements tout est fait
automatiquement c'est déjà pas mal tu as
pas besoin d'acheter 150 pendules 150
échiqué et cetera et cetera donc c'est
vrai que tu as aussi cet avantage là
quoi c'est économe quoi et puis tu as
pas les billets d'avion à tout le monde
à acheter machin et tout si tu fais un
truc plus international mais chacun joue
une play zone tu fais un truc à Paris tu
fais venir 50 personnes un peu partout
dans le monde billet d'avion machin ou
quoi tuas très vite pour 100000 € quoi
non mais oui non mais tu fais des trucs
à Paris avec des des Français des Belges
des enfin des gens proches tu fais un
truc à Londres tu fais un truc à
Barcelone tu fais un truc Munich et tout
en même temps centaines de milliers
d'euros par tournoi et New York et Los
Angeles et je sais pas quoi écologique
du tournoi aussi tu pou beaucoup
moins donc ça mais ça c'est le projet à
terme c'eston qui est pas encore je
pense que ça si loin quoi je p je pense
que c'est une obligation un peu pour
tout le monde d'y arriver
enfin mais après oui en fait disons les
tournois hybrid il aussi une histoire de
cadence j'imagine mal hybri pour du 40
coup 2
he av c'est que pour du Blitz maximum 5
+ 2 en
fait du je sais pas mais c'est pas pour
les parent en tout
cas des truc sur de TR jours max mais
c'est efficace mais d'ailleurs c'est un
format qui marche bien
enfin a beaucoup de s'organise comme ça
mais oui je suis d'accord pour qu'il
devrait faire ça pour tout ce qui est
rapide bon pour l'instant fou qui fait
sa partie il il a mieux géré son temps
que d'habitude d'ailleurs il s'est pas
mis trop en PLS il est encore 3 minutes
mais il par avec du retard hein donc ça
va il va tenir facilement en fait ti
bien pere faire F6 monter le
roi
ouais non il va ti facilement parti a
pas été
emballante mais bon après il a chois une
solide et tant mieux parce que bah lui
c'est ce qu' cherche avec les
Noirs monter le
roi sur ro de le C lancer
5 on dit car vraiment foutu on peut
jeter un œil très rapidement surtout que
nous on sera plus en direct je monte à
fond et le roi a l'air ko il a de pion
en plus oui bon ouais il est vraiment
foutu bah écoute il faudra absolument
qu'il batte la laav
demain et il se qualifiera probablement
grâce à la victoire
contre sera quand même favori pour se
qualifier en qu de victoire contre la
zavi de
justesse bon maisav il essaie encore
joue Caren demain c'est ça ah oui donc
il est très bien en fait iar encore il
est encore très favori en fait pour la
qualif à une victoire sur 6 c'est
incroyable il a encore de trois petits
trucs à régler hein dans la
position réfléchir le roi ADV un peu
plus actif ça doit pas être si
impossible mais
bon
de mon côté ce que fait par curiosité il
est contrej contre
abdouon il les noir il é très
content c'est tout noir lae est toute
[Musique]
noire très très
chaud on verra S se arnaquer ou quoi
mais bon il encore 4 minut 30 donc il
est bien
autant ça va faire 6 sur 6 c'est 7 sur
il peut la perd faant ça
plusoue souci on sait
fachanger
Mach très bien pour
plus bon je dis pas qu'il a perdu du
tout se tient maisas plus de temps
et tu peux facilement faire une erreur
sans calculer dans ces
position à 5 maisentend évidemment parce
qu'on Pasir C4 faut vraiment qu'il
accélère mais oui il faut jouer jouer
une 26
44e 16 jouer comme ça avant d'avoir du
Raj une seconde par
C
en fait pour que Maxime gagne
aussi demain je sais plus mais il a de
victoires qu'il
gagne comme ça que Sin en fait il a
perdu contre Maxim matpartage à contre
quo il il a du bien
troll dur à dire j'espère que nous
écrira tout ça dans l'article nous
expliquera un peu tous les
enjeux
après j'ai du mal à voir cavalus ça
l'air fort là tu vas gagner
B3 mais si tu forces le roi advers en C2
très passif to ton cours vient faire le
taf il va être obligé de jouer avec fou
de fou B4 pour essayer de prendre le
pion c'est pas mal il arrive à être
précis avec peu de temps par contre si
pas Magnus ikarou sera éliminé dans tous
les cas parce que même s'il gagne il se
retrou à égalité avec Maxime tu l'as
battu il l'
battu mais je vois pas Magnus
B sur un
match serait B Magnus fe exprès de
perdre comme il est sûr de gagner car et
comme ça il est mini carou
c'est pas le genre de la maison mais moi
j'aurais fait par person mais bon
pourquoi pas fait que
trollerimin my
queen
3 mais
bon un peu vite0
ça fait comme
ça GAE toujours ça va le trop bien
par contre sa technique en qu' Gén un
peu cata
donc avec peu de temps je pense qu'il a
pas forcément les bons
réflexes il a quoi a 46 secondes j'ai
56e coup va pas tomber c'est une bonne
nouvelle
j'entend de voir un peu les autres
scores à côté juste pour tenir au
courant donc plus il y aura des changes
de pion plus se rapproche de la nulle en
tout cas c'est pas mal Fabiano a
gagné
ouais en fait normalement je me
rencontre très vite mais le problème
c'est que là comme on a un délai énorme
quand on a un petit problème je sais pas
pourquoi on l'a eu deux fois aujourd'hui
c'est rare mais faudrait que je vérifie
les
branchements ça juste débrancher je vais
regarder euh HM
aujourd'hui on avis qu'on bug
ouais il bug
complètement du coup on a été mute
pendant quoi une minute peut-être ouais
ouais on s'en rend compte mais là
ouais faut que je regarde le branchement
il a dû avoir un problème
aujourd'hui de toute façon on disait
rien de très
passionnant une belle muraille le RO
blanc qui peut pas s'infiltrer
ouais ça va se terminer là-dessus
Fab
ouais fait le taf une fois qu'il a plus
de pion f Il pour aller prendre le pomb
et ciao petite
nul qui remporte ce match ik qui a perdu
on le
sait qui a gagné on va faire Clement et
on se retrouvera demain donc classement
Wesley qui est leader devant
Carl
3 donc c'est ce que je te disais en fait
pour il va battre laav demain et je
pense j'esère n font l'article
mais Maxime joue le match de 4 contre 3
il aa un intérêt aussi
Maxime gag en fait particul c'est
important
pouriit de
Perre parce que même si Fabiano gagne il
revient aveeco il sera derrière en en
goage particulier moi si Carsen je
ferais exprès de perdre en
faitit c'est dans son intérêt de faire
exprès de perdre ouais parce queiko pe
tous être dangereux ouais moi je le
feraai si tu as le choix enfin tu avais
qu'à être devant j'ai envie de dire pour
moi c'est pas truqué le tournoi enfin
genre tu es devant tu es devant enfin je
vois pas pourquoi tu aurais pas le droit
donc à la place de Carlsen moi je feris
exprès de tank le match parce que
firouja c'est quand même un adversaire
pas trop dur tu fais G4 F4 tu tankes
merci au revoir non mais il y a rien qui
t'empêche non c'est de la gestion de
tournoi ils adorent la gestion de
tournoi gère le truc machin donc tu
gères ton tournoi tes Lini carou de
manière forcée parce que si Magnus perd
ouais ikarou passera la trappe avec la
zavic les deux plus faibles finalement
qui sauterait ah oui mais les zavic en
fait il peut espérer que firou gagne et
que Maxime perde il lui passeraai
devant don Maxime faut qu'il gagne en
fait pour les T de figure fa qu'il
bon nos Français qui ont leur destin en
main demain ouais non ils ont leur
destin aura forcment sauter s per ah non
ouis donc on aura au moins un Français
la suite mais peut-être de on pourra
suivre alira peut-être contre
Magnus qui pourra éliminer Caro et se
qualifier au passage on espère en tout
cas ce serait beau ça ça serait parfait
allez B on se retrouve demain passe une
bonne soirée demain donc à partir de 18h
bonne nuit à tous ciao
ciao